e
I think I think we're going to give a
few minutes here um to see if more
people come in and right now
not one person that's a sponsor co-
sponsor on this bill is here so I'm
minutes
e
okay we can all take our
seats
yeah welcome to the um Science and Tech
and energy committee uh as is tradition
we will begin our committee meeting with
the Pledge of Allegiance I will ask
representative Noel to please stand and
please
hearing is not open and I would like to
uh say that right now uh chairman Vose
is in the Senate giving a a testimony so
he'll be back shortly in the interim I'd
like to introduce uh Senator avar to
introduce Senate Bill 303 thank you Mr
chairman and chairman committee uh uh
and thanks to the committee I'm Senator
avard District 12 and uh I am the prime
sponsor of this bill and it was at the
request of the Department of energy and
uh so I'm going to ask you to treat me
nice because I got your chairman in my
committee right now
so anyway uh yeah I'm the prime sponsor
of this bill and basically the bill adds
uh battery storage projects to the use
of renewable energy fund it deletes
required re renewable energy generation
incentive programs and authorizes a
political subdivision incentive rebates
and Grant programs using this fund this
bill also modifies reporting date by the
department of energy concerning the
renewable energy fund and again like I
said it's at the request of the
department who is here also I believe to
answer some really technical questions
if you have them but uh so this bill was
um it makes changes on how the energy uh
the renewable energy fund is
administered to better align with its
current happening in the energy sector
the re renewable energy fund is funded
through alternative compant payments
made by electrical distribution
utilities and competitive suppliers who
cannot acquire enough renewable energy
certificates to comply with state law so
the department then uses These funds to
provide grants and rebates to renewable
energy projects that generate more
renewable energy certificates in the
future needless to say that the energy
sector is moving by Leaps and Bounds and
the state program needs to be able to
keep up with the market changes in order
to ensure that the limited State funds
are making the difference in these
projects happening rather than just
subsidizing projects that are happening
anyway perhaps the most recent uh
perhaps most importantly uh this bill
directs the department to establish
programs specifically for political
subdivisions this will help our cities
our towns our counties to reduce their
energy costs by reducing pressure on
property
tax Senate energy and uh recommends the
passage of by four to zero in the full
Senate passed on this on a voice Voice
vote and I hope my friends here in the
the house will vote the same way so if
you have some light questions I'd be
happy to answer other than that I got to
get back the committee thank you Senator
does anyone have a burning question for
the senator so we can get out of here
quickly represent K thank you thank you
Mr acting chair and this is a quick
question I mean
uh it says in the analysis that it adds
battery storage projects that's great I
just don't see it in the actual bill as
as as it come to us it looks like it
took the battery storage language out
when when it was amended but so I mean
just could you clarify that for us like
where I cannot but I'm sure the
yeah okay yeah perhaps we can the next
speaker might be able to to clarify that
representative Corman do you have
question for the senator I had the same
question as representative Kaplan great
mind stick
aik seeing no other questions seeing no
other questions thank you Senator I need
I know you need to get back so thank you
you do yeah I'm
sorry I'm sorry we want to let you go
Senator I know you have stuff to do um
my question was around uh whether there
was any discussion in the Senate on this
bill about the change that cuts
generation from support under the RF
funds was was it discussed what kind of
impact there would be if we were no
longer supporting um renewable
generation projects because that was you
know where it was focused before and
this kind of changes that Focus I think
the emphasis is is to uh basically fund
new projects and not funds that are
already existing and I think that's
that's where the emphasis is on this
bill okay thanks yeah with that
representative Thomas you have a burning
question for the senator I'm sorry do
you have a burning question for the
senator I do well I mean he's the prime
sponsor correct yes so I do have a a
question of the Prime sponsor yes I do
great thank you thank you for for
acknowledging that um online uh 16 and
17 on uh the first page of the bill it
says in italics or may modify existing
programs or opportunities could you
identify what those are I'd like I think
the department can actually speak to
that better than I could
okay okay that being said Sandra thank
you so much thank you appreciate it all
right I will call on the next uh speaker
and the only one I have right now and
that is Mr Josh Elliott from the
energy good morning in Mr chairman
members of the committee for the record
uh Josh Elliott I am the director of the
division of policy and programs at the
New Hampshire Department of energy uh
we'd like to thank uh the sponsor
senator avart for introducing this bill
on our behalf um so I'm going to just do
a walk through of the Bill of what's
what's here what's not here um and then
happy to to take questions um as the
committee may
have so walking through the bill um as
amended by the Senate section one is
just a reporting date change um
the uh you may recall in um House Bill 2
there were a number of changes made
around when alternative compliance
payments were made um this uh
inadvertently short changed the time
that staff have to actually review those
payments as they come in to ensure that
they're actually the correct amount that
should be paid um so this just by
reverting it uh pushing it back a month
from October to November um restores
that initial timeline um that was
contemplated it just didn't happen to
get caught in House Bill 2 uh section
two of the bill um makes two changes um
the uh afor mentioned from uh
representative uh Wendy Thomas uh
regarding uh modifying and existing uh
programs or opportunities um basically
gives us the authority um the the
previous process um had been uh done
through a pu docket process um this
would give the department the ability to
change and modify programs obviously
including stakeholder input as as part
of that process
um to be able to make those sort of
minor tweaks as as um uh the situation
dictates the second section the second
piece of of section two 19 lines 19
through 24 um is the reference to the
municipal program that Senator avart
spoke to so this is a specific direction
to the department to create that uh
program for municip or for political
subdivisions so cities towns counties
Etc um we have found um through process
with federal funds that there's a
tremendous amount of demand for solar in
particular um from municipalities but
the current program structure does not
allow um does not provide enough funding
in order for those programs for those
projects often to get off the ground so
this would allow us basically a specific
carve out for um political
subdivisions uh section three is just a
cleanup
um uh I'm sorry I'm skipping section I'm
sorry Section 3 Roman X as well as
section 4 um repeals the statutory
requirement for the residential uh
rebate program um and this is not
because the department doesn't want to
offer residential rebate programs it's
that the statutory construction is
particularly uh strict um in that it
requires us to give a rebate to anybody
who's had a solar array that's been
installed uh since 2008 so this array
could have been put in place in 2010 and
then um they could come in and get a
rebate if they haven't already gotten
one um the department is committed to um
reviewing a uh uh uh
reviewing uh a new m a new residential
program in the Solar area essentially we
uh the existing program
um uh has been um trying to think of how
to phrase this I should say as as part
of this we have done a public uh
stakeholder um in session um back in the
fall reviewing the comments one of the
con common points was that this
residential rebate program is not
functioning as though as it should
essentially it is just serving to
subsidize uh solar projects would have
happened otherwise rather than actually
incenting new ones from
happening um so as part of that process
um we of course will engage with other
stakeholders to figure out what that
right program design looks like um in
order to be able to provide those uh
rebates to um solar projects that might
actually make a difference rather than
ended up just subsidizing into existing
ones um section four Roman 11 um is just
a cleanup um of the existing statute
just retaining the um direction that we
do the program every year and then
section five is the effective date um
there was a little bit of confusion um
regarding battery storage it was in the
original bills introduced by the Senate
the amended analysis did not capture
that change in the amendment um so
that's why you still see that reference
to batter storage there it was removed
by the Senate um based on comments from
uh that were heard in the Senate
hearing uh however I do want to note
that the fiscal note um is still
accurate for the bill um with the
exception of any of the references to
battery storage are are no longer there
so with that I am happy to take
questions from the
committee thank you Mr Elliott I might
make mention before we get into
questions um congratulations on taking
over uh we understand that Mr Griffin
Roberge is moving on uh we thank him for
his uh being here all all this time and
thank you for taking over as now so I'm
sure U uh uh you both will be doing just
fine I uh we're it's a loss for the
department but um I can't say uh you
know we're we're very happy for him as
much as we're going to give him a hard
time about it very good okay uh
representative rolds
question thank you Mr chairman uh well
particularly since the prime sponsor
pointed to you uh could you Enlighten us
on the uh Senate's thinking and the
Department's current
thinking uh in respect to the removal of
references to battery storage from this
bill I mean uh as probably the next
testifiers you know
testimony describes in great detail
battery storage is obviously an
important and
emerging piece of uh particularly the
efficacy of Renewables and
so you know are the programs are the
programs you envision now going to
support um you know integrated solar and
battery storage or or what sure thank
you for the question so this came up
during this as you as you mentioned
during the um uh during the Senate
hearing um about a question about
whether or not battery storage in itself
actually generates energy certificates
um yes uh which it does not um so the uh
the question that was raised by some of
the uh testifiers during the Senate
hearing what had pointed that out and
said these don't generate wrecks the
underlying premise of the renewable
energy fund is to incent uh
new um sources of generation that
produce recck so in theory right it
should be a
self-fulfilling uh uh cycle of which
there are not enough wrecks these wrecks
go to to um fun F projects that then
generate wrecks in theory in the future
fewer wrecks are then needed so
alternative compliance would go down and
sort of a continuing cycle like that um
as part of that process right you would
have to be able to generate those wrecks
this um battery storage in in itself
does not generate wrecks because it is
just either taking electrons either Off
the Grid or behind the meter usage um
from an existing uh generation which
then is then used by the consumer and
doesn't actually go out onto the grid um
so there was that that question about
whether or not it actually um generated
Rex and therefore would be a appropriate
use of the renewable energy fund I will
say during our stakeholder sessions uh
we did ask the question uh a number of
folks uh who commented responded
positively that yes a battery incentive
program would be good um the uh the
testimony in the Senate was limited to
um individuals taking issue with it um
rather than being in support of
ahead well thank you for that response I
guess in followup my my question I mean
obviously batteries don't generate any
electricity but as I stated in my
opening question batteries increase the
efficacy and the value of renewable
energy
systems so I I think that distinction
and the the Senate doing what they did
is um
kind of myopic uh so I'll ask you now um
you know I'm I'm gratified that at
least uh remaining language in the bill
refers
to renewable thermal and electric energy
projects for political subdivisions is
it the
Department's
position uh
or does the department consider battery
storage
to potentially
be a
valuable
component of renewable energy systems
that could be supported by the renewable
energy
fund I would I would answer that as a
qualified yes um there is a policy
decision to be made there about whether
or not the renewable energy fund should
be used to um provide funding to
projects that don't in and of themselves
generate wrecks um that is policy
decision that the legislature can make
so represent
Harrington thank you um question on the
topic of battery storage if make make
sure if I'm following this correctly
then what you're saying is that most
battery storage if not all is associated
with renewable energy projects so a wind
project the solar project for example
produce uh renewable energy and they
receive recks for that now those recks
are either sold to a um one of the
utilities or one of the electric
providers or they uh you know those
providers provide alternate compliance
payments instead but but they're already
that electricity that's produced has
already been awarded reck now when it
goes into battery storage it simply sits
there and then some hours later it gets
re re-released back to the grid it
doesn't produce any more electricity so
paying question coming please okay this
is what I'm saying the question's right
here paying recks to battery storage
would appear to be paying double Wrecks
for the same amount of electricity once
when it's produced and a second time
when it's released from Storage is that
correct that that would be correct if we
were awarding Rex for uh electricity
that was discharged from batteries
however that's that is not contemplated
in this bill well that's what was
changed in the bill by the said uh no
that was that was wasn't part of the
bill as originally introduced but um was
the question that the policy question of
whether or not renewable energy funds
should be used to provide incentives for
battery storage all right followup well
I thought you had to follow up with the
second question but ahead well I'll make
this one real quick um you mentioned the
alternative compliance payments the goal
of the original program was that we want
to produce more renewable energy so a
long-term goal would be to see
alternative compliance payments go to
zero so all of the money from the wreck
all the all that money is being produced
is going to produce more renewable
energy how where will we add in that
goal of getting of making it so we don't
have alternate compliance payments um
that is an excellent question it is one
that is often um impacted by policy
decisions in other states um within the
uh ISO New England region the Rex can uh
be traded interchangeably um what counts
as a class one here is a different class
in Massachusetts is a different class in
Connecticut Etc um there other states
have different requirements in terms of
what can be settled what of Rex um
there's a if you look at our annual
report there's a very complicated chart
that sort of shows all the overlapping
what counts as what where in New England
um but that being said if New Hampshire
were sort of an isolated bu in of itself
and those wrecks did not go anywhere
else right you would have that sort of
mechanism um that would function in that
way um but there are outside factors
right there are policy decisions made by
other states that then impact what the
wreck Market looks like so just by New
Hampshire and of itself um can't
necessarily
um uh that sort of that envisioned
process um is impacted by outside
factors that are beyond the policy
Hampshire begee thank you Mr acting
chairman and thank you Mr Elliott for
taking my question um so what I see in
the amendment before us um is a couple
of changes that are called out by the
analysis and then the first one about
batter storage actually no longer is
modified by the existing Amendment um
what I see is that we are saying that
the renewable generation incentive
programs as they currently exist would
go away and they would be replaced with
programs that would be um designed by
the department of energy to support
municipalities and political
subdivisions um in adopting renewable
energy projects would that be a safe
analysis um no so we are not undermining
any of the the current programs that
exist with the exception of repealing
the specific residential solar program
due to the efficacy issues that I
mentioned earlier but the with the
desire and the goal and the intention of
the department is to replace it with
something better after going through a
robust stakeholder process but the
existing programs that we offer for
example um the um uh non-residential um
competitive grant program uh the uh low
moderate income uh solar grant program
the commercial uh solar rebate the
commercial wood re uh wood pellet rebate
as well as the residential wood wood
pellet rebate um would remain unchanged
okay so I have a follow-up so first of
all I would like us to establish how
much money is in the RF in any given
year so we can have an idea of how much
money we're talking about and then I
have a followup from there sure um I
would need to look back at our latest
dedicated funds report um to to get the
exact figure as of where we sit right
now um as well as check with our
business office as to an exact balance
okay um we ACP Revenue sort of varies
from year to year depending on the the
variety of factors um that I said in in
response to representative Harrington's
um
question um last year we received I'm
trying to recall off the top of my head
I think it was about 7ish million dollar
in ACP revenues um so far this year has
been committed uh $4 million uh in
programs um part of it was uh
contemplated of looking at um these
statutes and bringing this bill forward
engaging those stakeholder conversations
um to make sure that the programs that
we have are effective they're working
the way that they're intended and
they're actually beneficial to folks you
know it would be um you know wouldn't
serve the the people of the State of New
Hampshire if we came up with programs
that nobody wanted them right um so we
want to make sure that those dollars are
being spent in the most effective way
possible okay and then can we uh before
we get to your second follow up can I go
to representative months first then we
can we can come come back to
you all right you're off the hook I'd
like to give the representative a chance
here go ahead than thank you Mr chair um
and my apologies for arriving late and
if I'm asking a question that was
already answered uh my apologies as well
thank you for taking my question um you
know SE section four eliminates um four
or five very
specific um sections in statute
currently um can you explain why that's
necessary sure um the uh program in
question is the residential program the
statute itself is is very um strictly
constructed in to the point of where the
department is required to offer a rebate
to any uh residential solar system
that's been installed since 2008 that
has provided has not received a rebate
So in theory you could have which is the
example um I mentioned earlier you could
have somebody who's installed a solar
array in 2010 come in and ask for $1,000
rebate um we did conduct an initial
stakeholder session uh requesting
written comments in the fall um the
common Point among all of them was that
this current program is not functioning
uh well or as intended uh so so with the
strict statutory
construction that's outlined uh
currently in statute doesn't give us the
flexibility to make it for example means
test it or to Target it to certain areas
or do sort of all those S programmatic
changes um that would make it a more
effective program um that being said the
department is is committed to coming up
with a replacement for this program that
we would um put into place obviously
after stakeholder input and things like
that um to make sure that the program
that we're designing is actually um
doing what is intended to do rather than
just what you know we on the inside
think would be effective but talking to
those folks out in the field follow
follow
up so why would we eliminate something
before we have a replacement uh
identified um the program without the
the remove or I say without this change
we would continue having to basically
operate the program as is and there's a
question about whether or not that is
the best use of money in the RF to
continue spending on a program that we
effective representative mcke as you can
have the final
question thanks um I think there was a
hand up over there too but um so my
question is around our we don't seem to
have a lot of information around behind
the meter solar and it seems like those
individual solar installations actually
are having having an impact uh on demand
it may be the place where there's the
widest spread adoption for the way our
policies have been structured in the
state so do we have any information
about about um the the current impact of
behind the meter solar which I think is
kind of elusive in terms of the the
numbers that we look at thank you for
the question so part of it is a bit
tricky because it is all happening
behind the meter and the the grid as a
uh and in llarge doesn't see it because
it it's not the only I should say the
only way that that it's seen by the grid
as as a as a larger entity is by a
reduction in demand um and um I'm sure
has been mentioned multiple times in
this committee the ice of New England
app has the great um uh demand curve for
all of New England you can see that it
sort of comes up in the morning and then
there's a drop off in the middle of the
day and then there's sort of a spe steep
steep Spike as folks are getting home
and as the sun is getting down um but in
terms of of that that generation or that
removal of the demand is really
dependent on those individual homeowners
depending on what they're doing what
they're doing at those times as well as
whether conditions and variety of other
other factors yeah I I get all that I I
guess it's it's hard for us to
understand if we're using the RF in the
correct way or designing the right
programs if we don't have that full
picture if if you could if your agency
could try and develop that for us so we
had a better understanding of where we
are saving currently in the addition of
renewable generation then maybe we would
be able to design a program that really
got us where we want to go faster and
that would be the intention sorry if I
can respond to that um that would be the
intention of the Department of making
sure right those dollars are going to
the right places rather than subsidizing
somebody who already has
one okay uh well I will representative
Thomas um unless you have um a brand new
question let's make this the last one
and I think we're starting to go around
in a circle here so what's your question
uh it has not been asked before um
referring to lines 20 and 21 on page one
this is developing an incentive or
rebate program or competitive Grant
opportunity for renewable thermal and
electric energy projects for political
subdivisions my question is what is the
Department's plans on how to inform and
publicize that these new programs exist
sure so we um probably taking a step
back um we would do a stakeholder
process to figure out what exactly would
work for municipalities who engaging
with uh with folks either it be the
developers or the municipalities or
through the municipal Association and
other entities um to figure out you know
what are Town's really looking for right
we don't want to design a program where
nobody wants and we want to design it
where the the demand
is um that being said um we would
publicize it we would work with folks
like the municipal Association we work
with Town energy commit to make sure
that these um programs are well noticed
and well um uh well advertised to the
the folks who would actually be in the
shoes of of drafting these applications
for when the competitive Grant programs
open go ahead thank you um it sounds
like there there could potentially be
money left on the table what would
happen to
that I'm uh I'm sorry where where would
money be left on the table if if
application if not enough applications
come in um or the stakeholders don't
know about it and they don't apply
sounds like there there's a potential
for money to be left on the table yeah
um so in that circumstance thank you for
the question in that circumstance um
what has been the policy of the
department is to just carry forward the
funds into the next year um for the
program so additional funds would just
sort of roll forward um there is a
requirement that we rebalance funding um
as the um uh Within two-year period just
to make sure that the spread between
commercial industrial programs and
residential matches what the actual
electricity demand
is okay um I think we've covered the
realm of questions
here thank you uh Josh Mr Elliot and the
the the new Griffin Rivers well
temporary at least
temporary um I don't having I don't
thank you very much I don't see any
other you
do I'll be so
yes okay if uh please be quick putting
your card in next time because uh there
we have a sander here waiting absolutely
so um I apologize I wasn't planning to
speak um but just wanted to jump in I
heard a number of questions that I
thought uh I could clarify on um Sam
Evans Brown executive director of clean
energy New Hampshire um we are in
support of this bill um we were in
support of it when it was uh looking to
add battery storage into eligible uh
uses of thef we heard heard the concerns
about the fact that battery storage does
not generate uh wrecks and therefore
shouldn't be considered but you know I
frankly think that may that concern is
may be a little overblown um there
really is a need for those type of
funding in uh the stes state of New
Hampshire but even as written I think we
would support this bill there is a real
need for funding streams for municipal
projects and our circuit Rider program
sees that every day um there there are a
lot of really Innovative and exciting
projects that municipalities are working
on that don't have flexible sources of
funding that can that can fund them um
and just as a again a very quick note we
also do not see the residential solar
rebate as being additive we believe that
at this point that that program is
really just sending money to folks that
would have installed solar regardless
and so we support the elimination of
that program and using those funds for a
better and higher purpose and that we've
come to that conclusion through a lot of
consultation with our members that are
in the residential solar space so um
ahead representative par thank you chair
and thank you uh Mr Brown for your
testimony um my question is um I
understand from your letter uh we're not
talking Rex here for Batteries but
because this bill was originally
directed towards batteries and not
towards replacing uh a part of our rsas
with a as of yet to be written law um
I'm feeling at a loss when I'm reading
this bill I'm thinking that we do need
something to flatten the curve and
batteries are what we need if not Rex
something else can you explain why the
focus of the bill deviated from that to
replace um rsas with as of yet Unwritten
policy uh so so I would agree with Josh
Elliott's characterization that the
concern is that the the renewable energy
the renewable portfolio standard is a
self-balancing policy right so you if
you have not enough renewable energy
credits uh alternative compliance
payments are used to create projects
that generate enough renewable energy
credits that make the alternative
compliance payments go away so so I I
understand that concern that that the uh
investing in technologies that do not
generate renewable energy credits
undermines the policy design of the ren
renewable portfolio standard currently
there's only one program that I know of
that is is uh putting money on the table
to make batteries happen it's the clean
energy fund which came from the 2017
divestiture of of psn's eversource's
generation assets um the the residential
the residential battery program is fully
subscribed the commercial battery
program um the you know the rebate
levels aren't high enough and so there's
that we are trying to work with
eversource and the doe to to figure out
how to get that money out the door but
very limited funding I mean the the
whole clean energy fund is $5 million uh
and and the the the programs that are
welld designed that money goes out the
door very very quickly so uh we were in
support of the initial idea because
although there was the potential that it
might mess with the RPS design there is
a real need and there aren't many
programs in New Hampshire that are that
are getting batteries deployed so we
viewed that as a trade-off and something
we were willing to
support okay with that thank you very
same EV Brown I declare close the public
hearing for S Bill
303 since we're running a little late
we're going to move right on to the next
bill which is Senate Bill 388 and
welcome Senator Pearl U thank you for
being here I know you're busy uh
appreciate you coming before us well
good morning members of st& for the
record my name is Senator Howard Pearl
from District 17 I live in the Great
town of Lowden and uh pleasure to be in
front of your committee today I am here
to introduce Senate Bill 388 relative to
the administration of utilities by the
department of energy th this bill was a
request from the doe and it makes some
technical changes to uh the rsas that
govern them and I'm going to let uh Josh
explain those in detail because he'll do
a better job than I will additionally uh
the department has requested an
amendment since the Senate hearing
there's a couple of more technical
changes they've discovered they'd like
to make so they're they're going to
present you with language for an
amendment and I'm fully in support of
that if the committee decides to add
that onto the bill there shouldn't be
any objection from the Senate on that so
with that I'm going to uh hopefully let
you call Josh next and let him give
explain all the technical uh aspects of
the Bill thank you does anybody have a
question directly for the
senator representive
Kaplan thank you Mr acting chair and uh
I'll make this you know hopefully you
able to answer this Senator um what was
the intention of changing homeowners to
households on line uh 20 that's section
two section three Net
metering it says you know low moderate
income used to be homeowners now it's
going to be households what what was the
thinking behind that thank you
representative it's great to see you
again yeah good to see you and uh I'm G
I'm honestly going to let Josh answer
that it was a technical change that the
department requested is and they felt
better represented the language than
what we currently have thank
you see no further questions thank you
Senator I know you're busy you can get
back to your real job well your your
chair was over there in front of us
testifying so it was a good swap I guess
well thank you all have a great day
thank
um that okay so the next the only other
pink card I have on 388 is Mr Josh
Elliot from the Department of
energy another request from the
Department of energy I'm sure you will
describe what the changes are thank you
again good morning Mr acing uh chair
members of the committee again Josh
Elliot from the uh director of the
division of policy and programs from the
New Hampshire Department of energy um
just like to uh reiterate our thanks uh
to Senator Pearl for um introducing this
bill for us um so I am going to go
through sort of a section by section um
of the bill um to give you a sense of
what it does CU there's lots of little
sort of little changes here and there um
that will help the department uh
function more effectively and um be able
to um be able to provide better value to
the citizens of the State of New
Hampshire um going through the Section
by section uh section one and two um
this is just a clarification that uh
public utilities are required to comply
with Department
orders um with section two being the
penalty mechanism for not following
those um the commission currently has
this uh statutory Authority while the
department does not so that's just adds
in or the department um in those two
sections um section three um to uh
representative kaplan's earlier question
um the change from homeowners to
households does two things um it uh both
makes the statute consistent um
households is in other references in
that section um as well as ensuring the
clarity that um home home owners has a
very distinctive you actually own the
residence that you live in versus
household um makes it clear that yes
renters are eligible for this program as
well so it's not just constrained to
those who actually um who own their own
home um whatever it may be um sections
four and five of the bill um this is
another technical cleanup um regarding
the date of when the um renewable energy
fund annual report is filed um these
sections do not conflict conflict with
what is in Senate Bill 303 so you can
leave these here and leave the one in
303 and nothing's going to get knocked a
skew um but just make sure that those um
dates all then line up um with the new
timeline that was established um in
House Bill 2 for when all these
mechanisms happen uh section six of the
bill um this gets into our assessing
Authority um which is what we do um to
the utilities um in order to provide
that regulatory oversight we conduct an
assessment on the utilities for that um
for those Services um
the um for entities that U make less
than $10,000 in Revenue in a particular
year are exempt from the statute um
unfortunately a lot of times we don't
know what a entity's revenues look like
until we send out the assessment so
we'll send out the assessment and then
oftentimes we will get back oh you know
what here's our exemption or we want to
be exempt um which is fine but then you
have to recalculate everything based on
that exemption so this provides a very
clear window and direction that if you
are filing for an exemption to the
assessment here's the period in which
you do it so our business office isn't
constantly recalculating recalculating
recalculating every time one of these
things comes back in we do communicate
with these entities
frequently um you know Things fall
through the crack there are staff
changes things like that happen but that
that um makes it clear that our business
office is just not continually turning
and recalculating these assessments
um sections seven and 8 of the bill um
these are just holdover statutes um that
existed when uh that were carried over
from the former um officer strategic
initiatives um they're no longer
relevant to the department and can just
be removed from statute um I realized
based on the the title of the sections
about personal Wireless Services um I
just want to make it very very clear
that this does nothing to change
municipalities um ability or authority
to regulate cell phone towers in their
own communities so that is kept intact
this is just removing the department
from it because there were there were
just some straggler statutes there
um that being said um as uh rep as uh
Senator Pearl um referenced we have two
additional changes um that we would like
um to see made that are just purely
technical um if the letter that I
believe is is going around as on the
back side of the page so references
those two um changes one of them is a
change to section three um just
clarifying that um for this um program
that only new solar installations are
are eligible rather than existing ones
that then become one of these um and
then adding in um at the very end of the
um section on line 23 um allowing the
department to rank these projects based
on their demonstrated project Readiness
um so essentially we just want to avoid
the situation where someone could come
in propose this great project that um
says provides you know 100% of the
output to um
LMI um customers um for benefits on
their bill um but is clearly not project
ready and there's certain things that
demonstrate project Readiness such as
site control um looking at
interconnection um there's a whole you
know Finance firm financing plans and
things like that we wouldn't want to see
um Bad actors coming in with projects
that then um eat up that capacity um
that mean then viable projects which may
have slightly lower because they
actually have calculated what they're
supposed to be doing um then get knocked
out so while there might be this sort of
Pie in the Sky um project that comes in
um that would get selected without
having this criteria to be able to judge
based on Project Readiness um the last
two um requests are are combined um are
actually um dealing with uh House Bill
232 um which I know Mr chairman you
sponsored last year dealing with thermal
wrecks um um just adding our favorite
phrase um by rule or by order um to
those two sections of Statute that were
amended um to allow that alternative
metering methodology um that'll make it
clear that we can do this by order um as
an interim before the formal Ru making
process begins um so we' had a couple of
conversations with folks who are who
work in this area um and this is a this
is a um certainly a desired change that
would help the department be able to do
implementation faster than um current
statute would allow
so with that uh Mr chairman I'm happy to
pause and take any questions I realize
it's a lot of disjointed pieces all over
the place as technical cleanup bills
tend to
be thank you very much questions from
the committee representative McGee thank
you Mr chair and thank you Mr Elliot for
taking my question again um I have lots
of questions uh but I'm just going to
start with uh section six on uh line 11
page two and my question is it says any
public utility or other assessed entity
could you define for me as part one of
this question what what other assessed
entities would qualify or would be
required to be noticed
here that is a good question I would
like to just double check with our
business office to make sure I wouldn't
want to Fathom a guess and have that
guess be wrong okay um but I'm happy to
to get back to you and the rest of the
committee as to what those other
entities would be thank you and then on
the bolded um part from line 14 on until
it concludes uh that paragraph on on
line 18 I was a little confused because
it it basically says you know you you
you need to request this exemption you
need to get your request in here's the
period it's from July 1st beginning of
that year uh and we need to see it by
the 30th so that's I guess a 30-day
period my question is are there any
processes around this is it push is it
pull how do people become aware that
this law is changing so that they can
comply
and because it just it seems a little
vague in the way it's defined here and I
didn't know if there was any other
statutory language anywhere that
actually would uh help people understand
what their requirements are yes so these
um and now that you've asked that
question and i' I've thought of one of
the assessed entities that might be so
competitive suppliers for example would
be considered an assessed entity I am
not sure how much further broad it gets
but that's at least one of the answers
to your previous question um or
regarding the process um this is
something that we do on a yearly basis
um these entities are required to
register with the department so we know
who these folks are we have their
contact information um certainly any
change like this would be communicated
well in advance of saying you know as
the assessment period comes up if you're
you know with this language if you're
seeking to file an exemption you know
you this is the period in which you can
file an exemption before we go through
all the work of actually calculating
everything um so that that Outreach
would happen to make sure the entities
aren't caught by surprise and somebody
doesn't file something on August 1st and
then oh sorry no like there would be we
would communicate these changes to those
assessment is it an electronic form or
is it
paper um that is a good question I can
check with our business office on that
um I believe you know what I'm not even
going to Fathom a guest I will check
with our business office folks who who
work on this and um and get an answer
for
you further questions from the committee
representative
Kaplan thank you Mr chair and thank you
Mr Elliott I have a question about the
uh the the U the additions that you
would like to see in this in this bill
and that's uh the you know the handout
that you just gave us addition two and
three it seems that that has to do with
with useful thermal energy and the
wrecks that they can receive uh I just
wondering could you
quantify the the number of of plants if
you will that would be that would be
affected by these changes sure thank you
for the question um so uh House Bill 232
um um which uh passed the legislature
last session um uh sort of sought to be
able to meter um uh I should say get
around the uh not get around address the
issue regarding small thermal um Rec
producers typically this would be um you
know if it's a small facility um um all
the way down to the size of somebody's
own Uh Wood B wood pellet poer in their
that they use for home heating for
example um the statute the statute um as
written has the word meter in it which
has a very defined definition of um but
also uh needs to be a revenue grade
meter um in order to be able to match
those tolerances because there is um
your in theory where you would be
generating renewable energy certificates
from it you need to have a revenue grade
meter so you know exactly what is
produced in order to know exactly what
um uh the number of wrecks that are
being produced from that facility um
those meters are quite qu very expensive
um so for the smaller systems it does
not make any Financial sense to be able
to uh to actually install one of those
because whatever installing one of those
types of meters is going to be far more
expensive than any of the the uh Revenue
that you would generate from any of the
wrecks that are being produced um This
was um brought forward by a number of
folks last year um about trying to find
a uh happy medium in between the two of
developing sort of this alternative
metering methodology for those smaller
facilities that doesn't require one of
those Revenue grade meters
um so they would be able to be eligible
to um produce um thermal recks as well
followup question I follow up so I don't
so would the rules or orders produced by
your department would that have to do
with with requiring or allowing those
kind of meters um it would as the
statute as it's constructed um requires
us to uh approve an alternative metering
methodology that is proposed through a
stakeholder process um but the way that
the statute is constructed um it would
require us to go through the entire
formal rule making process um which is
can be long can be a long process um and
obviously there's a there's a question
with um of just changing one SP small
part of the rules versus a holistic
looking at all the rules in in in a
holistic sense because then you if you
change one little piece here you might
inadvertently cause an issue somewhere
else that is then can't be rectified um
by adding the language um by rule or by
order um it allows the department
basically to issue an order which has
the full effect of of um rules as an
interim until the formal rule making
process looking at all the rules within
that section puc 2500 in case anyone's
curious um done on a holistic basis but
make sure that the statute itself can be
implemented before that holistic role
making process goes
through further questions for Mr Elliott
representative
Bernardi thank you Mr chair uh Mr
Elliott these amendments to this
procedure just procedurally when are we
going to see them what's what's the plan
here um thank you for the question um I
would defer to the committee I'm happy
to work with anyone who would be
interested in in in um having OS draft
these amendments happy to work with OS
um but I just offer them to the
committee for their consideration um for
addition to the
Bill thank you since you have provided
written uh versions of the Amendments we
can take it from here thank you
representative
Noel thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question uh in your
descriptive uh uh paper uh you refer to
sections one and sections sections one
and two uh where the public utilities
are mandated to comply with the
Department orders uh does that ALS does
that work in conjunction with the Pu or
is it an exclusive uh uh Mandate of
authority to the department um thank you
for the question um no it is adding uh
so that the existing statute that you
see here being amended um is for the
Public Utilities Commission to have that
Authority um our request here is just to
add the department so we would have the
similar authorities to the puc in just
in just in these regards okay thank
Thomas yes uh thank you Mr chair in
Section 8 on line 30 um the the repeals
relative to guidance and rulemaking by
the department of energy can you tell me
what specific aspects of guidance and
Rule making are being repe repealed um
sure uh thank you for the question my
apologies um yes those um sections um
deal with um personal wireless service
facilities um that had the department
that the well I should say at that point
it would have been the office of energy
and planning um um in the early 2000s um
was tasked with coming up with um a
number of sort of finite um proposals
around the sighting of of personal
Wireless facilities cell phone towers um
that has then been superseded by um uh
further developments by the
municipalities themselves in terms of
how they look at these things um so it's
sort of it's no longer relevant um and
it's no longer within the purview of of
department
additional
questions seeing none I want to thank
you Mr Elliot for being here to thank
you Mr chairman thoroughly described the
bill and also describe your suggested
changes to it I have no more pink cards
on this particular bill so I will close
the public hearing on Senate Bill
388 and in 5 minutes or so we'll open a
public hearing on House Bill
you
e
okay ladies and Gentlemen please take
your seats it's 10:30 and we would like
hearing the next public hearing is on
Senate Bill 391 relative to Electric
grid interconnection for certain
customer
generators and I would like to call on
the prime sponsor repres Senator uh
avard from the Senate to introduce this
legislation thank you Mr chairman and
for the record I'm Senator Kevin avard
District 12 and uh thank you committee
members it's good to see you all again
how are you all
right so as the prime sponsor of this
bill
uh so business business are always
looking for ways to control the um
control and keep uh down the cost of
such uh cost like electricity more and
more businesses are looking to
installing solar arrays to help reduce
their cost by producing electricity on
site the interconnection for small solar
arrays is typically straightforward uh
although for larger solar arrays like
those of businesses and interconnections
can be very
complicated this already complicated
inter connection process is then further
Complicated by the lack of clear rules
of the road and for businesses solar
developers and for the utilities this
bill is intended to help break the Log
Jam uh with the process of providing uh
those clear rules of the road in the Pu
p900 rules I know I've heard from
companies in my district about the
issues and I'm sure many of them uh
you've heard from them as well and if
you haven't I think you're going to hear
from them
today this bill amends is amended by the
Senate and would have the department of
energy create drafted rules to address
this issue in a comprehensive way
ensuring Clarity for business looking to
install solar as well as solar
developers and the department of energy
is taking this issue very seriously they
work with members of the Senate energy
committee on the language to make sure
that the bill is workable and
implementable and while there are some
areas of agreement about where these
rules what these rules should look like
there are other areas of disagreement um
between those involved in sorting out
the issues and it will take some time
and I know there's several companies
here that can speak to their experiences
with this issue as well as the
department of energy who will be able to
lay out how this process will work uh
and having spoken uh with somebody just
a few minutes ago uh there's definitely
uh going to be some proposed
amendments because of rules and uh so
with that
um I will take any questions you have
but I mean go ahead Senator thank you
very much uh I would remind members that
we have 12 pink cards here we're going
to hear a lot about this
legislation representative Corman has a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you senator for taking my question the
bill as introduced had a deadline for
the rules to be adopted by December 31
2024 with the updated procedures in
effect uh the next day and the amendment
removes that deadline uh why it needed
some time to uh to create the rules
otherwise it wouldn't have been
workable
followup given that why not a deadline a
little further out rather than just this
amorphous bill that just says there will
be rules and we don't know when right I
think we adopted 60 days did we adopt 60
days Mike are you in
here Mike
Lata I think I think we had mentioned
that didn't didn't we adopt 60 days it
says that it will open a proceeding but
it doesn't say anything about when the
rules would be in
effect uh believe I it was my
understanding was after 60 days of
guess okay we got the answer to that
question we'll deliberate on that thank
you any further questions for Senator
avard representative Thomas thank you Mr
chair um can you please tell me why this
hasn't been opened as a docket by the
puc I cannot okay thank
you further
questions seeing none I want to thank
you Senator and I also want to ask you
if you could uh talk to me briefly
before you
I'm going to call on the next person to
testify and then I'll meet you right
over here we can do that AB we're in
exact session so okay so next up is um
representative Jim
Horgan of Farmington who wants to talk
change morning Mr chairman committee
members uh my name is Jim Hogan I
represent Farmington and uh District
straford County district one and what I
have is uh I'd like to introduce uh an
amendment to S SP
391 uh
Hotel uh I see this as a way of kind of
refining the interconnection process but
to be perfectly honest with you I do not
understand all I know I do have Mr
Campbell The Honorable Mr pachy Campbell
uh with me here today who is behind this
and uh well versed and I believe can
questions that's all I
have I'll attempt to answer any
questions you have
but I'm going to drop it all on Mr
Campbell sorry okay uh questions from
the
committee representative parshall we
have a yes thank you chair uh and thank
you for testifying do we have a copy of
the amendment
so the procedure according to house
rules is that we do not consider
amendments at a public hearing I do have
a copy of an amendment that was handed
to me right before the meeting began we
do not however consider amendments at a
public
hearing out of um respect for
representative Horan I allowed him to
speak here I just spoke to senator avard
about whether he had seen this amendment
and he had
not I will allow Mr cble who I
understand
is uh who has requested this amendment
to speak briefly about the subject and
the kinds of changes that will be made
but not speak to the amendment
itself so Mr Campbell if you want to
come up and give us an a synopsis
of changes that you would like to see
made then we'll consider those thank you
okay and and I and I do recognize the
FAA of not being able to get this to uh
Senator avard we did email him copies we
did reach out to his office we did call
his staff and ask for return phone calls
so I do respect this process a great
deal um I think the problem with the
bill you guys already identified there's
no end date for when they're going to
make rules um B I'm sorry uh my name is
pachy Campbell I am uh a real estate
developer I own a Solar Company I'm a
former State Rep here in New Hampshire
had the opportunity to serve like you're
serving and I enjoyed it
immensely um I also was before this
Committee in August of
2022 and the committee was gracious
enough to do a committee Amendment then
and we passed a bill as related to uh
timing of net meter credit Billings and
I think that the amendment that I'm
looking for is similar to that that the
problem is actually in the rules and I
think the law needs to be clarified
where there's stronger problems created
by the existing rules in
pc900 and that's why I'm asking that if
you're going to pass a bill that says
hey just go make rules say we're going
to make rules and they're going to be on
a b CDE e and we'll make rules around
that content that they'll be specific
criteria such as 10 days to respond that
you'll provide an email or a way to
communicate with the utility right now
under the current rules utility sends
you a do not reply email it's kind of
problematic you can't really communicate
with them so I'm sorry I think we need
to put in law that you will give the
customer generator or the contractor
ability to conquer to so very simple
things that I think are reasonable
you never know how these are going to go
but I I guess the the problem that I
have with the bill it with the current
process that I'm asking to be amended is
that I appreciate Senator avar saying
hey we need rules but as is typical the
amendment says we're going to open a
hearing and you're never going to know
when you're going to see those rules and
for reference we haven't seen any rules
on the bill that you passed two years
ago as it relates to payments and the
utility refused to make those payments
until the rules were passed and I had to
remind them quite aggressively that they
need to follow the law and after 18
months I finally got a letter from uh
eversource saying all right Mr Campbell
we will start following the law we were
just trying to figure out the process so
literally we have some utilities that
are acting Above the Law so that's why I
think it's important that we put
specific things in the law because with
respect to Senator
avard this is my folder on the rsas and
the laws there's over 100 pages of rulle
TOS in
p900 and I've highlighted a couple of
them um one of them for interconnection
agreements over 100 kilowatts the the
rule essentially that the utilities will
just tell you what they're going to do
in their annual policy there is
absolutely no rules they just do it so I
think there's a need for rules there um
when you look at responses it says
within 60 business days of receipt for
those of you who know what a business
day is that means 3 months before they
even have to respond to me as a customer
Custer that's why I'm saying
specifically in my Amendment you have 10
days to either say hey I'd like more
information or your application is
complete or ideally approve it the other
uh section of the rules that I think
creates a problem for the utilities in
that that they basically say that the
invent that you need an upgrade so you
need to go from a 10 kilowatt
Transformer to a 25 kilowatt Transformer
they actually review the whole
interconnection agreement they then have
you install the system system they then
have you verify that you really wanted
to upgrade the Transformer they then
have you get the local approval from the
exhibit B from the local utility which
means you now spent your 80 70 grand on
your solar system then they'll start the
process of what's a work order with the
construction Department from one
Department asking another department to
do something and that's sort of created
in these rules so one of the things I'm
trying to ask you to do is basically say
if you have a service this a 60 amp
breaker it flows into two directions
already that happened long before there
was solar it is a stupid device it it
either has 60 amps in or 60 amps out 60
and 60 doesn't equal
120 that you you ask the question about
behind the meter that behind the meter
means that that if I have solar here and
it Taps the line and this breaker is
calling for power goes into the house if
it goes out of this line it goes onto
the grid it goes right into the next
house as if it was behind the meter so
one of my big problems is they make you
do these these system impact studies
usually on the projects over 100
kilowatts took three and a half years to
not even get my approval in one project
I spent $37,000 on a study and I'm not
going to try and save the committee some
time but basically there's a capacity
map so in the amendment I talk about if
you're under the capacity map you're
approved by right because you're
spending three years doing a study say
the information that's aailable on their
website think about that I spent
$37,000 to study whether or not I could
do a 1 megawatt Project a customer
generator project when the capacity map
said there was capacity for 7 12
megawatts if you further look at uh
eversource's website their capacity map
is based on an analysis of if as if 50%
of their substation is offline for
service or broken so this capacity map
is already reduced to 50% then you
further look at their own website it's
says if you're doing a project and it's
over the capacity map then you do a
system impact study that's literally on
their website but that's not what they
do because they can do whatever they
want is they delay you for years and
years so I have two projects have been
critically delayed I've spent thousands
of dollars on studies that's available
on their website and worse yet folks
because of what I just explained about
the power I'm studying a bridge that my
kilowatts never go over kilowatts it's
physics it goes she has solar it goes to
his house maybe to his house it doesn't
go across the table over there you
shouldn't be studying a substation in do
for a customer generation project in
Rochester yet they're requiring you to
do that so that's why I'm asking for an
amendment in law that says if you're
under the capacity map no system impact
study that's basically what I'm saying
I'm also the other real big issue with
this and I'll try to be quick chairman I
know I'm pushing the envelope here um is
the the idea that if you need a service
upgrade my if you don't remember my C my
company does dual access trackers we do
primarily 20 kilow systems they are
twice as powerful as a normal solar
system so they're really like a 40
kilowatt system so almost without
exception if you're a residential
homeowner you have a 10 or a 15 kilowatt
Transformer so I need an upgrade I can
go to the construction Department I can
create a work order I've been a
developer for 25 years I've built all
kinds of stuff I know how to do a work
order and get a new service they do not
let you do that process until you're
done with the other process so in law
I'm saying if I submit a work order
you're going to give me an estimate for
that service upgrade if I come in and
say I want 60 amps 600 amps or 1600 amps
and that's as large as it'll be for a
customer generation this is customer
generation this is distributed energy I
support the current law here in New
Hampshire of small solar Diversified to
the grid if you pass this law these
amendments that I'm looking for you'll
see that balanced distributed energy
throughout the grid because the market
the entrepreneurs like myself will be
driven to go to spots where there's
capacity because it's going to be easier
to get the approval so with that I I I
hope you have questions can you
summarize the five problems you would
like to solve and each problem summarize
sentence ever source is
struggling there are bureaucracy that's
not helped by the
legislators and I think the problem I'm
trying to solve is that struggle that we
have a problem as installers ask
Regulators as Government ask industry
ask utilities I'm trying to solve that
problem for
everybody okay great thank you
representative licki has a question for
you thank you Mr chairman I don't see a
fiscal note on this however what I see
are a lot of things that are going to
cost money basically these uh upgrades
installations and so forth and these are
are these going to be socialized to the
rate payers through the um whatever
process because you know each of these
things that you talk about is going to
cost somebody money and if all rate
payers are going to pay then this does
not seem fair to me thank you for that
question and representative that is that
is the heart of the matter one of the
biggest problems this bill solves is if
you look at line 27 it said U product
costess for all Associated secondary
upgrades the customer generator should
be responsible for cost of all those
secondary upgrades I clarify in law
because okay sorry remember the
committee doesn't have that Amendment
and we're not considering an amendment I
agree with you 100% if you did if you
were to pass this bill I would suggest
it be amended that the customer
generator pays for all utility upgrades
currently rep representative if you do a
new service there's rules on what
utilities can charge they have to give
so many feet for free so many telephone
polls for free so there would be cost
shifting if you went in and said I'm
going to do a solar system and you
follow their current rules of what
they're allowed to charge you so what I
would propose if you're going to pass a
bill on rulemaking put in law that
customer generators have to pay for
those secondary
upgrades right thank you further
questions representative Kaplan thank
you Mr chair and thank you Mr Campell
for for coming in um I don't have a
question about the amendment because
we're not supposed to talk about the
amendment but I just I'm curious about
the process were you involved in the
stakeholder hearings that the that the
department held and or the Pu held to
determine what kind of rules they would
like to see in terms of interconnection
were you part of that of those meetings
and if you were like what what was your
what was your um impression of those
helpful and want to be kind I'm wearing
my kindness jacket I think that some of
the scariest words the English language
is hi I'm from the government I'm here
to
that's generally how I feel um so um my
involvement as a former representative
has not been you know I'm running five
companies I'm working fulltime I'm
father of five I'm married I'm doing
what I can to get down here and
hopefully educate you guys in the
process but to answer your question more
specifically I've done interconnections
in Massachusetts I've done them in Maine
I've done them with Liberty I've done
with unel I've done them with eversource
I've done hundreds of solar
interconnection applications I
understand what I I believe is the
problem and I think I'd like to
hopefully have you take up my Amendment
which I believe is the solution and that
input because I I've applied for a
formal complaint with the doe because I
don't think to answer your question I
don't think they did an adequate job in
their hearings I don't think they've
done an adequate job in their rulemaking
so 90 days ago I did form a file
complaint about the interconnection
process and the fact that it cost me
over a million dollar guys think about
that it cost me over a million dollars
in loss revenue on the this one project
if I wasn't a well-healed 54 yearold guy
with five different
businesses ever Source put back on the
table bankruptcy for me as a
developer there's a major major problem
with interconnection for customer
generation and I hope that this
committee will work with Senator avard
work with the Senate to do an amendment
that gives just three or four little
guidelines things like pay for the
second grade ulties let us do regular
work orders let us automatically connect
if we're smaller than the service side
and under the capacity map that's all
I'm asking thank you okay thanks now you
submitted a pink card to speak on this
bill you have just done that so correct
I'm going to move on because we have 10
other people who I appreciate the
opportunity and I hope that this will be
a fruitful discussion and we'll all
learn something so I will not be calling
you back up that's fine okay all right
thanks just want to make that clear all
right let's next hear from Jonathan
Greer thank you all representing uh wire
representative good morning Mr Greer I
understand you folks uh need to move
along this morning so we wanted to get
process no now it is now everybody can
hear me all right all right all
right thank you everybody um my name is
Jonathan Greer I'm the president of wire
Bel a fifth uh part of the fifth
generation of this family-owned business
I'm proud to be here and I'm going to
tell you a little bit about us and our
experience with solar we are a global
business with locations in England and
Germany headquartered here in New
Hampshire we Supply conveyor belts to a
variety of Industries food Electronics
agriculture automotive and more our
company's belts have transported spent
uranium rods parts for space shuttles
they've helped sort blueberries and a
whole lot of pizzas and chicken
nuggets we are just a small part of it
but in today's worlds most things we buy
have been on a conveyor belt at one
point or another a little over 100 years
in wire belt has done well we have a
great place to work full of fantastic
people we've been recognized by business
New Hampshire many times as a great
place to
work the most in the state I believe and
we have many great benefits among them
is a profit sharing plan which has been
impactful for many retirees I hope we
are an even better company in 100 years
but New Hampshire is not a lowcost place
to manufacture labor Health Care taxes
and more contribute to a constantly
changing landscape that we need to
manage well to be globally
competitive when we relocated to Bedford
New Hampshire in February of
2023 we were planning for the future we
invested in wrapping the 120,000 ft
facility in an insulating skin to better
manage the temperatures it gets cold
here in the winter we've taken steps
with our equipment Air Supply lighting
and more to manage our costs one of our
largest Investments on this front was
the solar array on our roof
2,455 solar panels were planned would
make up an 840 KW AC system designed to
offset 90% of our projected demand we
took out a loan to help fund these
projects looking at them as an
investment in our
future unfortunately we have yet to see
the full benefit of our investment in
solar despite being in our building for
over a year now over this past year
after moving to the to our new location
we saw our electric bills Peak at
$59,000
173 or yeah $59,000 in one month that
more than a
$52,000 increase in one month over our
previous
location knowing that we're we had
invested in solar and were paying
interest on those loans made some of
those months particularly
frustrating candidly I want to spend our
money someplace else I think that we can
do that to the benefit of our employees
and our
business for
context if we are up and running in
April as planned it will have been
roughly 2 and a half years since our
application and roughly one and a half
years since we had ass signed agreement
and those have been expensive paper
weights on our ceiling or on our roof
for over a year now please ensure the
timely adoption of comprehensive
interconnection thank you questions for
Mr Greer representative
Corman thank you Mr chairman thank you
Mr Greer for taking my question I just
want to make sure I understand you have
the panels yeah the photons are hitting
them something's coming out of the
panels but you can't use any of it
because you're not interconnected none
of it is actually going into your own uh
wires and circuits within the building
yeah so uh we've got many people who can
answer that much better than I can um I
think that there is a capacity thing
where we can't turn it fully on until we
get a recloser installed I believe but
there are other folks here who can
answer that better than I
can
okay additional questions for Mr
Greer seeing none I want to thank you
sir appreciate you being here this
morning next I'll call on Jonathan Leo
of associated grossers of New England
Leo good
morning so my name is Jonathan Le Point
from Associated Grocers of New England
uh right down the street in Pembrook New
Hampshire and I am here on behalf of
Russ Greenlaw today who's the senior
vice president uh he apologizes he could
not be here he's currently at an AG
board meeting this morning so I will be
reading his testimony on his
behalf chair Vose Vice chair Thomas and
members of the House committee on
science technology and energy thank you
for taking the time to hear the
perspective of our state's business
community on this important legis ation
today and a special thanks to senator
avard for his leadership on this bill I
serve as the senior Vice President of
Sales for Associated groceries of New
England and I am here today as both an
AG representative and a New Hampshire
citizen to Showcase support for Senate
Bill
391 AG is the largest retailer-owned
wholesale grocery Distribution Center in
New England proudly serving the needs of
independent retail Grocers since 1946
since our humble beginning AG has
consistently and considerably grown our
headquarters in Pembrook New Hampshire
currently spans just under 500,000
Square ft to accommodate the hundreds of
employees and thousands of products
necessary to provide for the communities
we
serve as you can surely imagine a
facility of our size and nature has
significant energy needs while large
amounts of resource consumption is
certainly not unique to AG our passion
to approach problems through a socially
responsible and solutions based lens is
in 2021 we were able to align both our
fiscal goal of reducing operational
expenses and our commitment to
sustainability through the installation
of a rooftop solar
array our 1 megawatt AC solar array is
made up of 3,400 solar panels that sit
on the top of our facility generating up
to 1.45 million kilowatt hours of clean
power
annually at the time of installation it
was the largest rooftop array in the
state and today offsets nearly 20% of
our total electric load we are
incredibly proud of this investment and
want to expand however the journey to
get where we are was not without its
challenges because of past obstacles and
the lack of process rectification since
any further pursuit of an array
expansion has been sever severely
quelled
for example our first grid impact study
forecasted unprecedented costs for
interconnection largely due to estimates
for specific equipment that had been
knowingly procured by other companies at
significantly lower prices to be clear
here though pricing was not the problem
it was the lack of set regul regulations
to govern such a process that removed
any opportunity for challenge or dispute
resolution additionally equipment
necessary for equip for interconnection
was substanti substantially delayed
without any advanced notice and
therefore we were unable to turn our
system on until 6 months after the
original go live date to further
exacerbate the issue AG was ultimately
overbill nearly
$40,000 with a less than Urgent Response
or correction from the utility I'm
confident we can all agree on the
immense frustration caused by paying for
an investment while it was an
essentially inoperable especially so
when you are overcharged again it is not
the supply chain disruptions nor the
billing errors that are the fundamental
problem just as it was not the
aforementioned cost discrepancies that
caused our heartache simply put the
current system in place or lack thereof
makes positive initiatives such as
cleaned solar energy and uphill
battle as you can see AG has been
directly impacted by the insufficient CL
ity misinformation and unpredictability
involved in such a process but it is not
for our own benefit that we primarily
plead this case implementing fair and
transparent interconnection procedures
provide all New Hampshire citizens
individuals and corporate entities alike
a Level Playing Field to fully embrace
the opportunities solar energy provides
with that we respectfully asked this
legislature to enable the Public
Utilities Commission to integr this
demonstration of equity for the
betterment of New Hampshire's
communities far and wide we appreciate
your consideration of our perspective
given our experience and we invite you
to reach out with any questions or tour
our operations in Penbrook at any time
thank
you great thank you very
much representative Carman you have a
question
okay thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question so uh the
existing array that you have that's
operational offsets 20% of your electric
load more or less correct and you're
looking to expand and and uh how much uh
additional capacity uh would would the
expansion handle so thank you for the
question so we are looking at right now
I don't know if you've ever been to AG
so we've got you know a warehouse an
office and a warehouse basically so
there's a dry grocery warehouse and a
refrigerated side both roughly the same
size the dry grocery side of the
warehouse is completely covered in solar
panels so we still have the whole other
half of the building that we could put
solar panels on and at the same time
we're looking to expand our current
footprint we're outgrowing our 500,000
square feet right now so we've begun uh
the process of expanding our warehouse
here in Penbrook and it would be great
to at the same time expand our solar
array um but unfortunately that's like I
said previously an uphill battle right
now
so follow up okay follow up yeah thank
you so it sounds like the expansion
would be about another 20% or so of of
your needs yeah there are other issue
issues involved that were this is a part
of our challenges with solar net
metering is also another right so so so
my my real question is if if it's not
even if it's not meeting 100% of your
needs then what's the problem with
interconnecting shouldn't all those
electrons just be going right into the
building yeah we consume much more than
that though um and I think it was the
problem was when we they're all running
now that one half of the building but at
the time of installation a year ago
for the previous testimony it was it was
a challenge getting everything hooked up
and it makes us hesitant to move forward
with any additional
projects if that and if that doesn't
answer your question I can definitely go
back to the team and get back to you
yeah okay we have eight more people who
would like to testify representative
McGee has a question thank you I just
wanted to ask uh how long of a delay you
experienced uh thank you for question I
months all righty I want to thank you
for coming to testify to us this morning
next I'll call on Kate T from New Leaf
energy and Kate I would pronounce your
last name but I can't quite make it out
on the pink card is it thank you to
tongle Tom to to to okay sorry no
problem at all it's a hard one thank you
for go ahead thank you and welcome
thank you very much chairman V and
members of the committee thank you for
the opportunity to testify today my name
is Kate to and I'm at the director of
interconnection policy at New Leaf
Energy new Leaf is a leading developer
of solar and storage at both the
distribution and transmission scales in
service of our mission to accelerate the
transition to a world powered by
renewable energy New Leaf is
headquartered just over the Border in L
Massachusetts and many of our employees
live in New Hampshire including two of
our founding Executives I myself grew up
in New Hampshire was born and raised in
New BR New Hampshire and I gained my
appreciation for the natural environment
hiking and skiing with my family in the
New Hampshire mountains my parents still
live in my childhood home in Newbury and
I spend many weekends there with my
husband and my two young
children before joining New Leaf I spent
the last decade working at the
Massachusetts Department of Public
Utilities as the distributed generation
and clean energy on buds person and
Chief of Staff during my time there I
was able to work with the distributed
generation industry government agencies
and the electric utilities to improve
the interconnection rules in
Massachusetts and see firsthand the
impact an efficient set of
interconnection Standards can have on a
state's economy and its residents New
Leaf operates in over 15 states across
the country and one of the key factors
that we consider in deciding where to
invest is whether a state has a clear
set of interconnection Standards to
ensure a predictable process timelines
and costs as well as opportunities for
dispute resolution and process
Improvement while New Leaf is active in
New Hampshire and we have three projects
in the interconnection queue we are
extremely limited in our ability to move
projects forward due to the lack of
access to information and Regulatory
certainty of timelines and costs
where're eager to invest more and to
grow our business in New Hampshire but
we're forced to focus our attention and
resources in other states where there's
a set of rules that both we and the
electric utilities can follow to ensure
an efficient interconnection
process Senate Bill 391 appears on its
face to be an obscure piece of technical
legislation but its impact is actually
simple without this bill it will not be
possible for distributed generation
companies to continue doing business
business in New Hampshire or for New
Hampshire residents and businesses to
make their own energy choices a lack of
clear rules of the road leaves New Leaf
and other companies in limbo with no way
to predict when our projects may be able
to come
online there are many facets of project
Development and Construction that make
an extended lead time unfinanced project
considerations such as site control
permitting and revenue agreements
require a considerable amount of capital
and resources to maintain and they also
have finite terms that are subject to
expiration for that reason distribut
generation companies are hesitant to
expend time and resources on a project
with uncertain viability and with other
opportunities exist with less risk and
variability so for these reasons I urge
you to support Senate Bill 391 because
without it New Hampshire will foreclose
an opportunity to strengthen its energy
security and New Hampshire residents and
businesses will be unable to make the
energy choices that are best for them
thank you very much for the opportunity
to testify today and for considering
this critical
legislation thank you for being here
apologies again for mispronouncing your
last name could you tell us are you
happy with Senate Bill 391 as
written yes I think it's the key and
most important thing here is for us to
move forward with implementing a set of
inter connection rules and standards um
whether that's done by Doe or at the Pu
I think we need to move forward with
getting those standards in place and to
have stakeholder engagement and
establishment okay great representative
migy has a question thank you Mr chair
and thank you Miss to for taking my
question um when I look at the bill as
written in front of me uh starting on
line seven uh the sentence starts the
Draft rules shall include detailed
applicability and eligibility
requirements in Provisions relating to
engineering standards review processes
timelines cost responsibilities
information sharing and transparency and
dispute resolution that are aligned with
National Best Practices including the IR
the interstate renewable energy
council's 2023 model interconnection
procedures in your experience is that
definition adequate for our Regulators
to be able to um pull together a process
be I don't know how much you know about
the IP
20221 report that came out on December
5th that was the result of s sp262 in
2022 which many of us participated in um
so we've been trying to sort of get some
recommendations for a while do you think
that this language um is sufficient
instruction because it sounds like we
have a a pending amendment that has some
very specific um uh try trying to sort
of jump to the solution rather than have
a process do you think this will get us
there I do think that that language is
sufficient to get us there um although I
do recognize what the other constituent
said earlier today about um the for
smaller facilities the potential of a
differing process in Massachusetts there
are three different tracks that are
followed for interconnection and there's
a simplified process that's utilized for
smaller facilities um I am familiar with
the process that was undergone prior to
this and participated in it and I know
that there was discussion about looking
at both the interconnection rules in
Massachusetts as well as the IRA model
rules in considering what should be
implemented in New Hampshire so I think
based on the language that's included in
the legislation um the process or
investigation to set those standards
would give an opportunity to consider
those separate tracks for
interconnection and I have a followup
sure followup and so the other part of
the process seems to be that um we took
out a timeline for turning around um
these rules based on an objection from
our largest utility I believe who also
does business in Massachusetts so are
they currently privy to or they
currently required to uh abide by the
rules that have been adopted in our
neighboring state yes they so they
already are functioning in another state
with those um with rules yes absolutely
Massachusetts has an interconnection
tariff and in that tariff there are
timeline requirements for the
interconnection process for all three of
the processes the all three of the
tracks included and eversource is one of
the Massachusetts Electric utilities is
required to follow the interconnection
Tariff okay thank you representative
liwicki has a question uh thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question I see in the bill it says that
uh any new employee positions required
to implement that this chapter shall be
approved by the fiscal Committee of the
general court um which implies that
there should be a fiscal note here
because this is going to be costing the
taxpayers money I also question how much
is this going to cost the utility
companies how many trucks how many
employees are they going to be need to
clear the backlog and to do all these
interconnections because these are casss
that uh will be borne not by the people
who are being interconnected but by the
utility
company um I there may be others here
who are better suited to answer that
question but I can tell you in my
personal opinion there are already
there's already an interconnection
process for each of the utilities in New
Hampshire but it's at the utili
discretion and so it doesn't have a set
timeline or regulatory certainty for
timelines cost and process for both the
customer and the utilities so the
utilities have discretion and um this
discretion is not being followed
uniformly so having a process in place
that's followed in my opinion shouldn't
incur significant additional costs to
state representative Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair uh and thank
you for taking my question based on
earlier discussions are you concerned
about um the apparent lack of timelines
Bill yes I I it would be my preference
to have um a set timeline for
implementation of the interconnection
process representative rol has a
question thank you Mr chairman um it
sounds like you're based on your former
position in Massachusetts you are
ideally positioned perhaps to answer
this question what do you think would be
a reasonable given given the fact that
our neighboring state and has these
standards already in place and our
largest utility also operates in
Massachusetts what would be a reasonable
timeline for New Hampshire our
department of energy to develop to to
run this process and given the fact that
they already did an investig
investigatory proceeding and got a lot
of stakeholder input what would be a
reasonable amount of time to give our
department of energy to publish these
interconnection standards and put them
in place sure I will certainly offer my
opinion I do recognize that having
worked at the department dep of Public
Utilities in Massachusetts there's of
course um lack of staff and bandwidth
that could constrain the department of
energy but I think that six months would
be a reasonable time considering there's
already been an investigation there are
model rules that are offered and we also
have Massachusetts the neighboring state
that has a set of rules that are um
efficient thank
you okay seeing no additional questions
I want to thank you for being here
appreciate your Tony thank you very much
next next up is Rick labre representing
now agilitas
energy we'd like to welcome Mr labre
back he used to testify before this
Committee in Years Gone by on behalf of
eversource
energy welcome Mr Le thank you for that
welcome it's great to be back um Mr
chair and all the members thank you so
much uh for allowing me to speak my name
is Rick La I'm currently the the
director of interconnection and utility
Affairs for agilitas energy which is a
small but growing solar and battery
storage company located in Wakefield
Massachusetts we own and operate large
net metering facilities in Milton New
Hampshire Dover New Hampshire and a
small project in Kean New Hampshire we
are actively engaged in early
development at uh numerous sites in New
Hampshire but as uh Kate toay just spoke
to it it is a challenging environment
here given the lack of rules um I want
to clarify one thing about the bill in
case it caused any kind of confusion
where it says the Pu rule
900 I'm going to switch to my other
glasses
sorry uh PC rule 900 shall remain uh in
effect until any rules adopted pursuant
to this section become
912a clarifies that pu 904 through
9008 are only applicable to small
customer generators and those are the
sections of the 900 rules that relate to
interconnection so the 900 rules only
have in it interconnection process and
procedures for 100 KW and smaller
facilities pu 91.0 TWD states
interconnection of large net metering
customer generators which is anything
over 100
kilow shall be governed by each
utility's interconnection practices as
set forth in its tariff filed with the
commission the PSNH eversource tariff
filed with the commission has a section
37 that doesn't say much of anything the
only thing of of relevance it says is
for all other generating
facilities meaning those that aren't
smaller than 100 the company must be
contacted for site specific
interconnection
requirements prior to interconnecting
the generating facility with the
company's
facility now the company does have
distributed generator interconnection
guidelines dated July 2019 on its
website and I know because in
my I should have mentioned prior to
working at a gilas I spent 30 years
working at ever Source this is probably
a key point and I spent the last 12
years as the manager of the group that
interconnects distributed
generation so I wrote those guidelines
the guidelines that are on the website I
wrote almost um singlehandedly you know
on a Sunday morning in my living room I
copied the Connecticut rules that were
part of a a a a Pura uh proceeding in
like 2015 that ever source's Connecticut
affiliate had to live with I said well I
might as well make them close to my
affiliate in Connecticut's rules as
possible but I tailored them somewhat by
taking out the elements that I thought
were a little Overkill were a little uh
unnecessary administratively burdensome
to eversource and I took out the vast
majority of
timelines that applied to eversource but
I left in the rules the timelines that
applied to developers you know you shall
have 20 days to sign this and return it
you'll have 30 days to send us a 25%
deposit things like that so there are
guidelines on their
website they were emailed to staff
members of the Pu in I don't know 2019
let's say 2020 but they were never
officially filed with the Pu commission
or subject of of a proceeding of any
kind so I just wanted to clarify that to
the extent anyone
believes there's not an urgency here
because p900 already has
rules there are not rules in
p900 there's a document on eversource's
website um that is from my perspective
now as a developer um woefully
inadequate to control the process the
process is much more uh important now
that the volume of interconnection
applications has
grown the system is being stressed and
and rules become much more important
why do we need rules they provide a
framework to control the orderly process
both the applicant and the utility have
responsibilities for an efficient
process the rules create performance
standards for the utilities and ideally
would also contain data reporting
requirements so that all stakeholders
are kept upto-date about adherence to
Performance
standards specifically timelines for
getting work completed transparency is
critical data must be made available to
identify weak points and focused
resources on improving those aspects of
the
process Massachusetts has an amazing set
of rules some very strict
timelines Kate toay could could come
back up and and testify further on those
there's even a very specific timeline
enforcement mechanism in
Massachusetts and miraculously ever
Source Mass I don't believe has ever
failed a timeline even though if you
talk to developers in Mass it's a
nightmare 10x what it is in New
Hampshire so be on guard that there are
ways even with rules to make them
ineffective so we have to make sure they
have some
teeth without rules disputes devolve
into finger pointing and second guessing
the de developers are in a very very
weak position to challenge any aspect of
utility performance the utilities have
almost complete control and can slow
walk or even ignore
disagreements the most frustrating
aspect of interconnection as you've
heard this morning from a few
folks is the inability to get questions
resolved and complaints
addressed based on my time with ever
Source I want to make it clear that the
reasons for this are the lack of firm
regulatory rules that contain enforcable
performance
metrics and also the general lack of
priority given within utilities I'll
speak for eversource to the de
eversource during my time there to the
deer interconnection
function employees that work in this
area are very hardworking professional
and dedicated to strong
performance however keep in mind that de
interconnection is a a nonprofit segment
of the utility
organization it is understandable that
utility Executives not the workers doing
the hard work but the utility Executives
do not devote significant effort or
resources or strategic thinking into
improving this
function while not the subject of Senate
Bill 391 I believe interconnection rules
should involve either penalties for
non-performance or better
incentives to the utility for strong
performance given a profit motivation
the utilities will find a way to
expedite interconnections a perfect
example is eversource's worldclass
Energy Efficiency organization that
operates with a shareholder incentive
mechanism for their
performance regarding copil 391 the lack
of a deadline I in the for a rulem is
disappointing I I think it
personally um with all due respect I
think it looks bad that it doesn't have
a timeline I think it hints at something
nefarious I hate to be a conspiracy
theorist but I don't even know if s SP
391 is needed as written the doe could
create a rulemaking now they could open
a docket for Ru making or they could not
I believe they have the authority that
pu has the authority so I don't know
what sp sp 391 is doing other than
saying open the proceeding within 60
days I think it needs a
deadline the doe has already had an
investigatory proceeding IP 20
22-01 they've collected a wide range of
stakeholder input there was General
consensus on the need for rules and
standards these rules are needed quickly
and they must be rules with teeth and
the agency that enforces the rules needs
to get engaged inure rule compliance and
to resolve disputes large and
small thank you and could you provide us
with uh any written testimony I could uh
clean this up and and give this to you
it's basically what I I essentially just
read what I will send you if that's okay
that would be fine we'd appreciate that
and I'm sure representative reels is
going to want to know what you think
deadline thank you Mr chairman but
actually that that wasn't the the the
question I was going to ask um having
asked that previously uh uh thank you Mr
bre for being here and um again of
course you would uh tell us tell us all
uh that you you know 30 years uh at
eversource including the as you said the
last 12 overseas
the group that that handled the
interconnection process and
um uh I I want to kind of ask some qu a
question here if the chairman if you'll
indulge me just I hope to illuminate a
little bit this is a very complex topic
that we're discussing trying to require
doe to publish rules for so I wanted to
try to um illustrate it here for
everyone's benefit um and so while we're
just closing I before joining the
legislature um I spent three and a half
years um uh with revision energy uh
selling commercial solar projects trying
to sell commercial solar projects and so
this interconnection we are familiar
with your background could you just ask
your question please yes yeah the
interconnection process the big Bugaboo
it would you what we're talking about
when once a developer submits a
interconnection
application uh is is getting that thing
called the system impact study
done and as you described interestingly
the way you wrote ever sources
guidelines uh for such
um you
um you took out the
timelines that applicable to the
utility while leaving them for their
developers
um would you that
it with respect to the system impact
study the things that are most
challenging now that you sit on the
other side as a developer is one the
lack of any standards for the time that
the utility has to conduct that
study um the electrical the the clarity
of the electrical engineering standards
that apply to that study
as as they indicate the need or lack uh
the need for any and the level of system
upgrades upgrades to the Grid in order
for
this um solar generation facility to
connect and then finally the cost
of any such upgrades that the utility
ultimately
determines our require
ired so like those three elements the
time it takes what the engineering
standards are and the cost uh my
recollection was from the developer
standpoint it was like you applied for
interconnection you kind of threw that
over the wall the utility took it had it
had it did it all itself and you waited
and maybe that study came back within a
year and it said okay you can
interconnect but you're going to have to
upgrade this this this and this and it's
going to cost this this this and this
and then that would just put the project
totally over the edge in terms of
economic viability is that what what
we're talking about here in this
interconnection you know this yeah
that's that's basically the process
yes appreciate the brevity of that
answer yeah yeah okay seeing no further
questions from the committee I want to
thank you Mr lre and I would appreciate
some written test testimony from you oh
I'm sorry I didn't see representative MC
Williams had her hand up thank you chair
Bose um I I just want to ask a little
bit more um about you mentioned
incentives uh both on the eversource
side and potentially on the developer
side for Speed schedule um my
background's in construction I'm very
familiar with damages for delay and also
Clauses that would provide an incentive
for Speedy um completion on a timeline
um do you have any experience with other
states or other other situations where
these have been applied either damages
or incentives uh for developer or
utility because I think that that's
something worth
exploring I think on the developer side
the the damage is you know being removed
from the queue if you don't do what
you're supposed to do you're typically
uh removed from the process you have to
start over
um I can't say that I'm aware of a
utility or a franchise
area that says if utility interconnects
you within X days you get x amount of
shareholder incentives certainly such a
process could be devised I believe
Energy Efficiency is somehow earns an
incentive based on the amount of capital
they deploy of Energy Efficiency
measures there could be something
devised um what we have seen uh more uh
often is a concept
whereby the
utilities with all the interconnection
required to put distributed generation
there's a lot of facilities that need to
be built circuits need to be upgraded
sometimes in the extreme substations
need to be upgraded uh protection and
control equipment needs to be upgraded
and right now the distributed generators
in most franchise areas the rules say
you pay for 100%
even if you've built a brand you know if
you've funded a brand new $5 million
Transformer at a substation say um you
could create rules it would be have to
be in law that say uh maybe the
developer pays a percentage of that
based on some engineering technical
metrics but a percentage of that $5
million investment has long-term
benefits to eversource's customer as a
whole and therefore that should be
treated more like traditional utility
investment for which the utilities earn
a
profit that would speed them up as well
if they thought for every million
dollars worth of DG related
infrastructure upgrades we deploy over
the next you know decades uh we're going
to get a small chunk it's going to it's
going to grease the skids and get things
moving so there there's a provisional
process like that in Massachusetts and
and elsewhere they're looking into
things like that thank you very
much okay I want to thank you for being
here and that's very Illuminating
testimony you provided next we'll hear
from Rockingham County Commissioner
Brian
chirichello The Honorable Brian
chirichello welcome back good to see
you thank you Mr chairman committee
members for the record my name is Brian
rello I'm the chairman of Rockingham
County Commissioners second largest
county in the
state um I'm just going to give you a
quick background as to what Rockingham
countyy is doing and the issue that we
had um so Rockingham County in in uh
during covid times we received some
federal dollars from the federal
government and um that's allowing us to
build a $77 million building to how my
um Sheriff's Department um registry of
deeds and my county attorney's office
and at the time um we had a building
committee that was looking at doing some
solar arrays that would be on top of
covered
parking um once weeded that arpa money
we decided that it would be better used
if we could do um an actual solar array
and so that's the approach that we took
and and bear with me one
second my eyes are not
that well but
um so we submitted an
application um to interconnect a 3.25
megawatt AC project 8,800 panels total
and there was some talk about businesses
doing smaller smaller um and I realize
this is a little bit bigger but uh but
it's still
important um so in November 2022 we
received a system impact study agreement
in May of 2023 6 months later the
utility confirmed the study would begin
on June
14th we were told the study had a set
timeline of 80 business days which our
developer um the people that are doing
our building are also um working with
the solar
piece um that it um it had slipped
through the cracks we were told it was
on course and the developer was told
that they were working on it and then
after 80 Days days we were told quote
unquote slipped through the cracks and
the study process had not in fact not
begun this was immensely challenging
news to receive as the project had
otherwise already been fully parented
and we have already committed to
specific project deadlines which became
entirely Out Of Reach why is that
important we're using Opera money so if
you're familiar with Opera money it
you've got a you've got to allocate it
by a certain time and then you've got to
spend it so any delays would jeopardize
um federal dollars being able to use for
the for the solar arrays um I had heard
one of the representativ mentioned talk
about the rate payers um and I realized
that businesses we're talking about
solar but now we're talking about um
government entities and one of the
things that we're doing is the the the
investment for the solar array in
Rockingham County over the lifespan of
30 years would return to the to the rate
pays of Rockingham County $22.5
million so this is this covers all of
the Rockingham County complex's
electricity our bill typically is around
$600,000 a year between 600 and $700,000
a year so it's
significant um but without any
rules it's it's tough um and having
rules set would would have made it a lot
easier for us you know to be told that
if was on on par uh and then to find out
after the fact it was not uh is
problematic so we're behind the
eightball a little bit I mean I think
we're still we can still manage it but I
I think that rules need to be in place
you've heard all the testimony here um
and I think uh that this story needed to
be told because it's not just businesses
it's also um municipalities um also
really briefly I also wear a second hat
I'm a town counselor in Derry and in
Derry we did a PPA uh smaller array but
same same thing um and that would have
lowered our kilowatt um cost to 6 cents
per
kilowatt we had the same problem at the
town of Derry um lack of communication
and no no set rules so this needs to get
fixed so um I'll end it there and I'm
happy to take any questions that anyone
may
have okay thank you seeing no questions
from the committee we'll move along and
I'll call next on Sam Evans Brown of
clean energy New Hampshire to give the
committee his perspective on this
legislation welcome back Mr Evans
Brown thank you Mr chair members of the
committee um I'll try to be brief uh
many of the points that that uh our
members and our organization might make
have been made already
but I will say that in my opinion this
is actually the biggest problem
confronting the energy sector as as as
it you know in
2024 um these interconnection delays you
know pick your generation type they
impact every type of electrical
generator it just happens that what
we're building right now is a lot of
Renewables and so that's why you're
hearing about solar a lot today um when
I joined this organization three years
ago this was the issue that I was pulled
aside and talked to about before I even
was on the payroll so this has been
stewing for quite a while we attempted
to solve this in 2022 with the passage
of h s sp262 passed on a bipartisan
basis um this bill initially was
intended to be a placeholder for
recommendations that would come out of
the Doe's inter connection investigation
um and frankly we were somewhat
underwhelmed by the results of that
investigation and so we said instead
maybe we should ask the the department
to Simply go right ahead and start on
rulemaking um stories like the ones you
have heard are in my inbox every week um
some that you may be would be interested
to know about uh the The Glenn house the
hotel at the base of Mount Washington
has been waiting for a year for an
interconnection study they've had to
delay their project for an entire year
town of Whitefield which is one of the
smallest uh lowest income towns in the
state one of the top 25 lowest income
towns in the state purchased uh they
received a USDA Grant to put solar on
the roof of their Town buildings uh the
town hall had their array installed in
November and as of last week they were
still waiting for permission to turn
that array on um so so as I said they're
these stories are quite prevalent um I
would say I've heard some things that I
I just want to address um developers
already are paying the interconnection
cost so the idea that this is going to
result in cost shift to customers that
aren't benefiting from from the arrays I
think is something that we can just put
to rest that's not the case developers
are paying these costs um however I
would hesitate to put into statute a
requirement that developers pay for all
costs um there's quite a lot to be
worked out in the question of cost
allocation for interconnection costs and
in particular uh in eversource territory
there are interconnection upgrades that
are being required that it's not clear
how necessary they actually are uh in
fact those types of upgrades are often
not required in the service territories
of other utilities and rate payers that
are not benefici that are not uh uh
paying for the the array and benefiting
from the array are benefiting from those
upgrades and so an example the classic
one that I like to give was this idea of
reclosers so developers are as to be pay
are being asked to pay for the upgrades
to multiple reclosers on on circuits uh
what a recloser is is essentially a
circuit breaker the skate controlled
circuit breaker that can be operated
from a control room uh when you swap out
a fuse for for a a recloser all rate
payers benefit from that because instead
of having to roll a truck to handle an
outage you can just hit a button and
test to see if the recloser can reclose
so this question of cost allocation is
there's a lot of thorny issues in there
and I don't think that there should be
it should be in statute that um that
that that that the developer shall
always and forever pay for all of those
upgrades I think that should be worked
out in the working groups that were
recommended in the doe
investigation um one one other note you
know we have heard that uh
interconnection cues are are incredibly
jammed up right now actually think that
having rules and certainty would help
with that problem because uh you know
there are the there are plenty of actors
in the space it is not just the
utilities that are part of the problem
here too developers can be part of the
problem and one of the things that one
of the behaviors that is somewhat
problematic is that if you are a
developer trying to build a project you
one of the first things you do is you
pitch that project into the
interconnection queue because you know
it's going to take perhaps a year or 18
months to get your study back and so the
so you're so there are sometimes
speculative projects that are being put
into these cues that are that are
clogging them up and if we had certainty
timelines uh that uh I think there would
be fewer of those speculative projects
and we would have less guming up of The
Works um uh I also concur that I think
the deadlines should be reintroduced uh
in an amendment um and I think uh that
we need to to get some clarity in terms
of administrative processes one one
concern I have going forward is that uh
as initially proposed this bill the ruem
at the Public Utilities Commission which
has fairly clearly defined
administrative rules and processes that
have been in exist for in existence for
decades um the department of energy
while uh doing a great job getting up
and running is a still somewhat new
entity uh and and I uh I I'm hesitant uh
to see them to see them owning this
rulemaking entirely I would prefer to
see the department of energy draft the
initial rules and then have the
proceeding uh undertaken at the Public
Utilities Commission and so with that
all end my
comments thank you appreciate that
representative
um Ms has a question sorry Chris I threw
a blank on your name for a minute I
don't know what that
says Thank you Mr chair um says I
haven't seen you in a while yes and my
apologies to the U committee for my uh
my lack of uh attention this morning um
and um uh my apologies if this question
has already been asked but I wanted to
ask somebody so I picked on you um the
um the language um talks about um and
it's in uh line six it talks about New
Hampshire's investor owned
utilities um does that include the co-op
is the Co-Op part part of this it does
not so this does not include the co-op
the co-op is not subject to pu
regulation so uh the the the co-op would
not be roped into this
followup go ahead so does the do
customers of the of the co-op experience
the same
difficulties um that's uh that's an
excellent question and I would happily
sort of go back to go back to my emails
and try to determine uh determine the
degree to which Co-op customers are
experiencing these problems um but I
actually wouldn't I wouldn't be able to
say with great certainty uh how these
problems are distributed utility by by
utility with here on the stand on the
spot representative MC Williams has a
question thank you shose um and thank
you Mr Evans Brown for testifying uh my
question would be from a reasonableness
perspective what do you think is a
reasonable schedule um if we were to
break this down into something that
could be feasible uh following up on my
previous question about pain share gain
share penalties for delay versus
incentives for completion on time what
is a reasonable schedule in your
opinion uh I would encourage you to ask
that question to the Department of
energy for for one I personally think
the that the idea that we could have at
least um you know a proceeding open and
going by by Midsummer is is not out of
the question um which I would argue
would mean that we could have rules on
the books by the end of the year but uh
uh I am not the department of energy um
I would I will look forward to working
collaboratively with them to make the ru
making process as smooth as possible but
uh it'll be their staff that has to run
it follow
up yes follow up um thank you for that
in terms of the legislation I I think to
clarify my schedule question is really
about how long should it take from a
developer submitting an application to
doing the utility analysis to actually
being able to install and then to
connect in terms of schedule uh again i'
I'd hesitate to shoot from the hip here
on the stand I mean I I think that uh
certain steps uh a 10-day requirement is
is certainly reasonable so you pitch in
an application getting response in 10
days I think is is something that that
um should be on the books the question
of what is the timeline for things like
a system interconnection study um I
would imagine that that that'll be a
question that's heavily uh contested in
the process of creating creating the
rules and so um I would want to uh
confer with our members to to see what
other states are doing before before
trying to to answer it on the stand but
uh as things stand now it's
untenable there's you have no idea how
long these studies will take and they're
often over a year with with simply radio
silence as to when your system
interconnection study might be completed
thank you for that representative licki
has a question um thank you Mr chairman
thank you for my question you mentioned
uh speculative applications coming up to
works and it may already be the case
that there is an application fee but if
there's not would you be in favor of an
application fee that would uh be
forfeited if uh a an application were
withdrawn uh I think I think yes is the
answer there is already an application
helpful okay we have three more
representative
partial thank you chair and thank you
again foring my question um was some
point out earlier that the this um
legislation is written doesn't do much
that cannot already be done uh
internally in the doe uh would you be in
favor of some type of uh teeth such as a
deadline added to the spills amended uh
yes I would be in favor of a deadline
absolutely thank
you okay we have four more people who
would like to testify so I want to thank
you Mr Evans Brown for being here and
I'd like to call next on Dan
Y no I believe it is or I may be wrong
about that but Dan you can um clarify
that when you get in in the chair thank
you andcome Harington like Harrington
but with a y or you can say yarington
could prefer uh the pirate pronunciation
okay so like representative Herington um
doesn't look like there's enough thank
you Mr chairman thank you members of the
committee um I'm just representing
unlike the folks who are representing
utilities and other things and uh solar
companies I'm just representing myself
and my family here so thank you very
much you should each have a copy of this
I printed out and gave to you um this is
just on behalf of myself my wife Sarah
and our three kids Logan Malcolm and
Owen we live in London are New Hampshire
um we are fortunate enough to have a
very nice house that we can put solar on
and we invested in that over the years
um the gist of my testimony and you can
read through this at your leisure so
I'll try and keep it brief is we've done
a several array we did one small array
when we started and then we added them
recently so the perspective that I'm
giving here is in the past was a lot
easier and some's happened in the last
like five six years that's made it a lot
harder and we should not have to stand
for this kind of bureaucracy when we
decide we want to invest in something
these are very basic things I mean we're
obviously not talking about over a 100
Megabots we're well under that for our
home but this does affect homeowners and
just residents in addition to businesses
I'm uh I I have my own business as well
so I'm very um understanding of the
challenges there but this affects
families if we say we want to it's the
same challenge we want to invest in our
Solar we want to invest in stable energy
so that we can help ourselves and our
neighbors help stabilize the grid um
which is better for everybody uh that's
the gist of my testimony here is that
it's taken way too long in our case it
was about four or five months we lost an
entire kind of prime summer uh you know
Generation season and um you can read
all the details in my testimony here I
kept it short but I shouldn't have to
send a 100 emails and make dozens of
phone calls to get this done we didn't
have to in the past and it's gotten
worse as this has developed I assume
based on the volume of you know new
developments so um I'm happy to answer
any questions like I said you're welcome
to read this over uh at your leisure but
um this this phrase here uh is really
key we moved my family here moved to New
Hampshire in 2003 so we've been here 20
years now and we relish our ability to
live free we want to be free of outdated
and onerous regulations free of sticky
red tape and free of overly complex
barriers to the responsible exercise of
our personal property rights if we
choose to invest in solar we want that
to be a reasonable process so whatever
we can do towards that end that's our
goal okay thank you very much
representative Corman needs to ask you a
question though sure thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question uh so I just want to clarify
you're talking about relatively small
residential and that it took you several
months and with which utility uh this is
with eversource is our local utility and
um we had done several arrays in the
past small arrays I think our total it
was like 10 mega 10 kilowatts I guess I
think our total is like 38 we but we've
done this over many years and we've
worked with uh the same company each
time to do the install so I don't think
the issue is there I think there's just
you know something wrong in the system I
much wiser heads than I have testified
it here today and I just want to provide
the uh perspective that this does affect
just everyday day-to-day payers you know
that's a whole bunch of money that's
just sitting on my roof that I don't get
to recoup and that's very frustrating so
it does make a difference this isn't
rocket science it's some kind of science
but it's not rocket science we should be
able to have rules and they should be
simple and clear and be able to move
these things forward quickly thank you
Mr yarington okay representative Mick
Williams do you have to ask a question
really quick okay um considering your
position is as a individual and it's for
residential solar do you believe there
should be two different tracks for
smaller versus larger array installation
and
timelines uh it sounds like there may
already be that and I not as familiar
with all the current rules and
regulations but that makes sense to me
that there's you know up to 100 under
100 whatever that is um whatever is
reasonable and like I said it just has
to be a firm process like my day job is
I make board games we know about writing
clear rules and there's nothing more
frustrating than like this is what the
rules say or if the rules just don't say
anything and if I say this is the rules
you need to follow the damn rules like
that's what the rules are there for so
it sounds like we have a mess of a rule
book here and we need to make a better
rule book thank you all right thank you
very much Mr Errington appreciate your
testimony here this morning thank you
all next I'd like to call on Lindsay
bergoin of revision energy and Miss
beroy I'd like you to uh keep your
testimony as brief as possible we need
to get out of here
um this hearing has gone on quite long
so we have understand the issue so just
give us any new information that you
have that can make it easier for us to
figure out what to do sure thank you
chairman good to see you all uh my name
is Lindsay berin I serve as the Director
of policy and government Affairs for
revision energy um we've been installing
interconnecting solar in the state since
2009 and dare I say may have um we
suspect we may have filed an
interconnected more systems in the state
than perhaps anyone else so um I am
actually not going to speak on the
policy topic today and instead um turn
it over to my colleague Megan anen who's
here to speak a little bit about her
experience in the field um submitting
these applications and we will keep that
brief um and then my written comments
cover more of our policy talking
points okay so we understand that there
are delays in the process we get that
we've heard it multiple times so you
don't need to repeat that message just
give us information that we can use to
figure out a solution thank
you understood uh my name is Megan Yulan
I serve as a project developer for
revision energy where I have worked in
Brentwood for the past eight and a half
years I've held roles where I was
responsible for filing and managing
interconnection applications for
residential commercial and Municipal
customers and overseeing the development
of around 200 projects a year today I
managed the interconnection process for
commercial and Municipal projects 50kw
to 5 megawatts EC o
apologies um I guess my testimony today
is to illustrate a couple of examples I
can expound upon what uh Mr yarington
provided for the residential customers
um the lack of comprehensive
interconnection rules has been readily
apparent throughout my work residential
customers are waiting months to turn on
their systems creating challenges where
when they are required to make loan
payments and pay electricity bills while
the system sits idle on their roof
recently in eversource territory
customers experienced an average
timeline of 17 to 18 business days from
submission of closeout documentation to
permission to operate with times where
it Spike to over 40 days so imagine
installing a solar system and then being
told you must must wait nearly eight
weeks to turn turn it on this makes it
incredibly difficult to give customers
realistic expectations effers has
significantly improved residential
timelines with new software and while we
appreciate those efforts our state's
utility customers deserve as you have
heard equal accountabilities across all
utilities for all project sizes and with
the assurance that the processes won't
change and dispute resolution is
available should things go wrong for
larger customers the lack of rules means
they are waiting months or even years to
be able to determine whether the project
can safely interconnect a few examples
that we wanted to provide to you today
illustrate this um in 2022 a key
nonprofit applied for an interconnection
of a 260 kwac project received their
system impact study agreement and then
their interconnection agreement by April
2023 total of five months more recently
a Manchester business applied for a
project half that size in June of 2023
and we were told just this past month
that the system impact study won't begin
until April 2025 which is 23 months
later and doesn't include the timeline
for the study itself which typically
takes 4 to 6 months making this a 27 to
29 month timeline this is not a onetime
occurrence timelines for these projects
above 100 kwac have recently increased
exponentially and these study start
estimates are on average 22 to 26 months
after the application
date uh I think what is new information
here is that this is um not just on the
front end we experien these delays on
the close out side as well we have 60
kwac Municipal project in Rochester we
submitted its closeout documentation in
mid December and we have spent the past
three months inquiring when the customer
will receive their net meter Swap and
permission to operate to no avail so we
can't give the city any expectations of
when they'll be able to operate their
system I think for those reasons um we
do seek a role making at the puc we
think that will meet the goals of sp262
in terms of providing timely cost
effective and predictable
interconnection standards um there are
really great robust um model
interconnection procedures out there
from both FK and IR um that can be
utilized which means New Hampshire
doesn't have to start from scratch and
can customize those and build upon the
Doe's investigation um we agree with the
comments on timelines um and in fact uh
the model interconnection procedures of
of both entities um outline you know
different types of project size level
one through four I think those have been
renamed um recently but what are
appropriate timelines for um folks
hearing back from utilities for each of
those size um uh kind of categories if
you will so thank you great thank you we
appreciate you guys being here all right
representative Kaplan has a question for
you thank you uh Mr chair and thank you
uh this is probably from Miss beroy um
and you do call for the for this Ru
making to be carried out at the Pu and
the and the the uh the legislation we
have is is calling for that to be
carried out at the department of energy
so can you just elaborate on what you
think the difference between those two
bodies would be in terms of the rul
making yes um for sure and I think as
you may note the original legislation
did include um the Pu being the
authoritative body in that regard I
think it's the the pu's role to regulate
utilities and this really is utility
regulation um in terms of
interconnection so we think that's the
most appropriate body we think it would
be great for doe to build upon the
investigation that they did and draft a
rule and then submit it to the Pu for
the rul making um to ensure a process in
which we can all
engage
thanks okay seeing no further questions
we've got two uh folks to go both
probably have significant things to say
to us so we'll hear first from Michael
Lata of eversource and then we'll follow
that up with Josh Elliott from the
energy good afternoon uh Michael Lata
repres presenting eversource energy
appreciate the opportunity to testify
before you today and uh provide uh a
little bit of the utility perspective um
and our experience with uh de
interconnection uh process uh first and
foremost I I want to make it clear that
eversource supports the development of a
Statewide de interconnection standard uh
that was our testimony in the Senate
we've been consistent uh with that
position throughout we fully engaged in
the uh doe investigation that's been
referenced several times uh and uh would
continue to engage uh in the stakeholder
um working group process uh discussed as
part of uh the final report on that
investigation over the past several
years um we have seen exponential growth
in the number of solar applications that
eversource has received although I think
it's it's pretty consistent with the
other utilities as well based upon our
conversations with them uh to put it in
perspective in the year 2000 we received
about a thousand uh interconnection
requests that went up to 1,500 in 200 uh
21 uh in 2022
4,300
2023 uh
4,700 and we're expecting this year uh
over 5,000 interconnection applications
uh that's a 3 37% increase um that surge
uh which coincided uh with around the
time of the pandemic um did result in in
significant delays has resulted in
significant delays and we have taken uh
considerable steps to address those
delays uh we responded by uh changing
our process focusing first on uh smaller
applications um the typical residential
solar
interconnection uh We've implemented a
FastTrack program for these smaller
interconnections where there is a a
quick review not a full engineering uh
review we've separated them out from
from the larger projects that are more
uh complex and take more time uh in
addition we have implemented uh new uh
software Management program power clerk
uh which allows an efficient review and
automatic approval of some project
and because of of those uh changes and
process improvements today we are
processing new applications I'm sorry
95% of new applications for solar
interconnection within three days which
I understand is significantly different
from the testimony that you heard here
today uh but the vast majority of
eversource customers are receiving an
initial turnaround within 3 days it is
on average about 45
um days after that for the installer to
complete the installation and then the
project is online within uh uh 46 to to
48 days that's the average uh AC for
solar
installations that said we understand
that there is more work and considerable
more work to be done to improve this
process in particular uh larger projects
over 100 KW uh the process to uh
evaluate and address those programs uh
we are in the process of continuing
Improvement uh and I just want to pause
here for a second um to be clear we do
not oppose uh a Statewide rulem uh to
set standards but we are not waiting for
that rul making we're not waiting for uh
the results of an investigation we are
actively incorporating uh meeting with
developers and incorporating their
feedback on process improvements um to
make sure that we are are turning things
around as quickly as possible while
still acting as a responsible utility
protecting the safety and reliability of
our system um larger projects which have
mostly been the the focus of discussion
today uh do require uh uh in some cases
significant uh engineering review uh can
have significant impacts on the Electric
System and require project uh impact
studies uh one of the um reforms that we
put into place with our project in June
of last year was an initial feasibility
review process so this is a a high level
look um at a a large solar uh
interconnection application and initial
feedback that we can provide to a
developer that says this is going to be
really expensive or this would not be
really expensive ensive and they may be
uh make the determination to proceed
with with the project a lot of the
projects that we have in our queue um
are very Dynamic uh some of them are
very mature projects some of them are
candidly conceptual projects and the
developer is sort of taking the utility
temperature on whether there is a
significant interconnection cost before
deciding whether to proceed the
implementation of that initial
feasibility study tried to provide in a
quick uh manner that that first blush
first look of whether this is uh costly
or
feasible in February of this year uh we
actually posted on our website an update
monthly a public interconnection queue
for all the projects that we receive
over
25kw uh this provides uh an insight to
other developers uh the number of
projects that we're reviewing as well as
as timelines uh of when those were
accepted so folks can get a sense of
where they are um in the queue again
this is updated uh on a monthly basis
and is available publicly on our website
we're currently uh as we did with the
smaller uh projects um more residential
in scale uh initiating a FastTrack uh
review process for for projects between
100 and 500 KW again one of the issues
with these projects is they are
currently lumped in with a queue of a
megawatt 3 megawatts up to 5 megawatts
for municipal projects those very large
projects uh can require significant um
interconnection study and in some cases
can have uh impacts on on a substation
which can be lengthy uh we think that
this fast track for these these larger
but midsize projects um will help to
expedite their review and try to get
them moving uh more quickly
in addition uh we have added added staff
we now have five uh staff members five
employees that are uh in our engineering
department uh doing these reviews um and
trying to turn these projects around uh
as quickly as possible
um we understand that there is more work
to be done we understand that there are
more improvements we can make to the
process that said we have been uh
diligently working to address the
shortcomings in our process which
candidly um was designed uh years ago
for a much much smaller uh volume of
projects as you heard from a previous
eversource employee who was engaged in
that process at that time we have made
significant and um uh meaningful
improvements to that process and uh just
to be very clear um eversource's
testimony my test testimony in the
Senate on the bill as introduced uh we
did Express concerns with the timeline
in the bill is introduced which would
have required puc adoption of a rule by
December 31st of this year the bill did
not have an effective date until 60 days
after passage and then 45 days after
that the commission was um required to
open the proceeding which would have
essentially started rulle making in
November of of this year with an
implementation of December
31st just based on a simple reading of
the jail car rules that was not feasible
and we pointed that out um I am happy to
answer whatever questions I
may thank you Mr
Lata everybody has a question we'll
start with represent McGee thank you so
my question would be a follow on to just
where you left off which is that date
was not workable in your estimation so
what date would be would it would it be
three months after that or you know how
kind of a process do you think we can
engage sure we think a 12-month uh
process would be uh would be appropriate
obviously I can't speak for the
Department of energy and the Public
Utilities Commission who would both be
actually administering the process and I
know in the Senate they express concerns
about at least the doe expressed
concerns about um uh sort of bandwidth
and Staffing in order to to do that
again we are actively engaging with
developers and making improvements to
our process we are adopting many of the
best practices um that have been
identified in the IR process so I I
don't want to leave the impression that
we're sitting on our hands can I just
follow I know other people have
questions and I need to get out of here
too and I also have a meter running out
but um the follow on question would be
um around the sort of the losses of the
folks who are waiting in that queue
right there's a there's an economic
impact that's going on for folks that
are waiting for us to do our jobs and
for all of us to get our act together
around rules that exist they're they're
out there so pulling that together
another year since we waited from the
passage of 262 in 2022 until now uh and
we still aren't really any further along
in being able to Define rules that
everybody can play by so um I I would
just push back and say the year doesn't
really seem tenable to me from a
legislative perspective because we've
kind of slow walked the people that are
in the queue already so
um do you think it's possible well the
question is you said you think a year so
you're asking for the your best case
scenario on behalf of eversource but do
you think that there that a shorter
process than that uh can be achieved
yeah I I think the answer to that is yes
I I do think a faster process can be
achieved and I think that um you know
whether it's ad hoc working groups or or
in World discussions among the parties
are helpful and I think that's um uh
certainly can help move things along
when I say a year that's a deadline
that's an end point that's not you know
when it has to be done uh hope ideally
it would be done faster than that
representative Corman has a
question but he changed his mind so
representative muns will take over thank
you um you talked you you described some
of the additional resources that you've
um employed to move things along
software Etc uh what I didn't hear is um
Human Resources I mean you know have you
have you staffed up um yes I apologize
if that wasn't clear in my testimony we
have staffed up we now have five
employees uh in our engineering
department doing the the uh
interconnection
reviews
followup and do you do all of the uh
interconnection studies inous or do you
utilize Outsource outside third parties
as well we we utilize uh third parties
as well based upon the complexity and
project okay seeing no more questions we
want to thank you Mr Lata and we're
going to give the last word of the day
to Josh Elliot from the Department of
energy I'm sure he'll have some
interesting things to say about this
whole
process good afternoon Mr chairman
members of the committee again for the
record Josh Elliot director of the
division of policy and programs um the
department is neutral on this bill um I
think the problem has been laid out
thoroughly by the uh previous speakers
in terms of what exactly the issue is
that we're trying to tackle
here um I will stress this um the
department is being asked to do this Ru
making process I know there were
questions about the Pu versus the the
doe doing it um the 900 rules will
eventually become the energy or 900
rules so Mak sense if we're going to be
doing going to be administering these
rules that we should go that the
department should be the one rather than
the puc doing this
process at a fundamental level and as
you've heard today this is a
disagreement um between the utilities
and solar developers that the department
is being asked to adjudicate here um in
developing these these
rules talking a little bit more about
the the rule process um Mr Lata sort of
uh outlined the issues that the
department had with uh the bill as
introduced we um had those concerns
because it would literally require us to
violate Jael car statutes so in order to
implement that bill as introduced we
would have been violating other areas of
State Statute um the rule process um the
uh and I would certainly encourage you
folks if you have not served on Jael car
to certainly talk to your colleagues who
have been on jail car or currently serve
on Jael car the idea with going through
a rulle making process and why these are
Draft rules is because you want to sort
out all of the areas of disagreement
ahead of time you want to present Jael
car with a clean set of rules that all
the stakeholders have had their input on
that everyone can maybe not agree with
but can live with if you have a
contentious Ru making process that can
get dragged out indefinitely and that
doesn't serve anyone's best interest so
the idea here of getting Draft rules
that can be submitted to Jael car that's
that are clean that everyone is in I say
agree maybe maybe a b too strong of a
word but everyone can live with is sort
of the ideal situation I know they're
bring questions on timelines and
requests for a firm timeline I get it I
understand it but really it is comes
down to how quickly can all the folks
who stalked here today work with the
including the utilities work together to
find areas where there are common sense
areas of agreement and where there are
areas of disagreement that need to
further work on and to start having
those hard conversations about where
those disagreements are and what they
can live with and what they can't live
with and what's a red line for them that
would make this process go all the much
faster if there are areas that we can
knock out and say yep we're all set with
that we're all set with that we're all
set with that the ru making process goes
that much faster I will just add um as
has been referenced previously There are
rules um in the 900 rules that deal with
small interconnection so below 100
kilowatts um in size above 100 kilowatts
it defers to the Tariff which are um
issued by each of the respective
utilities so for the small um customer
for example for the gentleman from
Londoner I did give him my business card
we can have our consumer services folks
FKS um get in touch with him to figure
out his particular issue but as you've
heard today most of these issues stem
from uh larger um uh arrays attempting
to interconnect to the grid so with that
mindful it is the afternoon already I
will I be happy to take questions from
the committee okay thank you
representative Corman does have a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
Mr Al for taking my question uh so uh
the first thing I want to ask is uh was
it the O's request that the timeline was
removed from the original bill but I
want to also uh
ask I mean I I understand what you're
saying that that the timeline depends on
how quickly stakeholders can actually
agree on things but it seems like there
are going to be some issues where it's
just going to be very difficult to get
everybody to
agree who is the appropriate referee
then to actually figure out the actual
rule that is a good question absent any
any of the existing rules you sort of
run into a chicken in the egg sorry my
apologies um thank you for the question
to answer your first question yes the
doe did request that timeline be removed
because it literally would have VI
required us to violate other areas of
State Statute um regarding your your
question right there are areas where
everyone is going to have to come into
an agreement the there's a bit of a
chicken and egg right there's no Hammer
here that we can force everybody into an
agreement on something because if we we
were to force everybody into an
agreement on something with these Draft
rules then it goes to Jael car nobody's
Bound by whatever that by our Hammer
they can then litigate it at jail car
and go through that entire process and
relitigate issues that we have decided
forcefully that hey this is this is the
side we're picking this is what we're
rules representative Kaplan has a
question thank you Mr chair this is a
similar question to representative
Corman about the process uh can you give
us an idea of what what the working
groups would look like that would uh
that you would draw on to to make these
rules and and how public a process is it
sure um we would certainly as like any
other state agency we would make this a
public process so any of the particular
parties who wished to attend or offer
input would be invited to attend um
obviously I know there's certain time
challenges with everybody about being
able to be able either offer quick input
so there probably be certain public
comments versus somebody who's part of a
working group who has that um time or
bandwidth commitment um but there
wouldn't certainly be any limit in
can't representative Ms thank you Mr
chair and thank you Mr Elliott taking my
my question uh you've acknowledged that
um this is a this is an issue and that
also it's um it's complex and it's going
to it's going to be the resolution of is
going to be very timec consuming um
why do we need this statute I mean why
why do we need this bill why can't the
the department initiate a rulemaking
process right
now so uh thank you for the question so
gel car as part of their Process reviews
whether there's statutory authority to
create rules rules have the full force
and effect of law um I don't think it
would be good policy to have state
agencies just making rules on whatever
they
wish okay who else representative reels
succinct question I promise
uh my question has to do with your
assessment and your testimony that
um rules would have to be drafted from
scratch do you
not feel that the recently issued IR
model interconnection procedures and the
existing Massachusetts
interconnection rules where our states
utility eversource is also
operates constitute a substantial basis
for a rulemaking that you wouldn't have
to we wouldn't be starting from scratch
U thank you for the question yeah and
thank you for allowing me to clarify um
in my in my comment in the uh testimony
letter uh was referenced to that there
are no existing interconnection rules
for larger generators so in that sense
we would be starting for Scratch are
there uh in terms of specific rule sets
for interconnections for larger
generators within the p900 rules so it's
not as though we are starting from
something and need to make a couple of
tweaks it is a sort of a full drafting
to your point yes there are different
models that are out there as part of the
the process that had been referenced to
earlier um there were six different um
potential interconnection um models um
that um had been offered as potential
starting points um those um are are
starting points right New Hampshire has
a slightly different regulatory scheme
than massachus Connecticut does sort of
importing something wholesale from
another state could lead to further
complications I think was referenced
earlier the what exists now for ever
Source was sort of cribed from
Connecticut um and has sort of outlived
its usefulness so just taking it Taking
an entire set straight from uh one of
these models um is is a starting point I
yes I agree to that uh or agree to that
um that sentiment but it will still
require refinement and aligning with New
Hampshire
statutes thank you okay seeing no
further questions and having spent
almost two hours on this public hearing
I'd like to thank you for wrapping it up
for us and for being here this afternoon
and now I'm going to close the public
hearing on House Bill
391 the committee will now take a lunch
break and return at
1:15 for a presentation by the
Department of Environmental Services
thank you very much see you
then
e
for
okay 1:15 time to resume our activity
for the day and and my first Duty here
this afternoon is
to apologize to the folks from New
Hampshire de for not starting promly at
1:00 but we had a run over with a
previous public hearing and it wasn't
fair to the members to truncate their
lunch break so we appreciate you guys
being understanding and uh we also
appreciate you being here so what we're
going to do for the balance of the
afternoon is have a presentation from
Dees and the Arab Resources Division and
you guys can take as much time as you
want we have nothing else scheduled for
the afternoon um so you're in charge and
we'll look forward to hearing what you
have to say well thank you for the
invitation first and foremost um I'm
glad you're all fed because uh I
wouldn't want to deal with that
situation so I can appreciate that um
you've asked for a lot of information
today in our email exchanges with
representative Bernardi so we will
attempt to to uh cover all those things
I'll first introduce the team here
myself Craig Wright I serve as the air
director for the air Resources Division
behind me I know you all know Mike
Fitzgerald the assistant director for
the air division to my immediate left is
Ted deers the assistant director for the
Water Division and also behind me is Dr
Jonathan patali so if you can change the
slide
Ted Ted said he knew how to do this so
okay there we go good job Ted um this is
just I'm not going to read all this this
is the basic areas where you guys had
asked for some information today and
we'll do our best to be prompt provide
information and answer questions of
course seeing that Ted is here we
decided to put the Gulf of main offshore
wind initiative up first and with that
I'll just quickly turn it over to Ted
for his couple
slides well thank you very much it's
great to be here uh and I appreciate the
opportunity to kind of talk a little bit
about getting you up to speed for those
of you who are not up to speed on uh
where offshore wind is headed in the
Gulf of Maine so I'm going to just uh I
really just have a couple of slides that
kind of talk about time frames but I'm
going to Veer off from that and give you
a whole number of updates in terms of
what is going on both uh regionally and
as a state uh the various different
agencies we are but one of several
agencies which are involved in this work
and we have a very active uh
collaboration with our sister State
agencies and I'll talk more about that
as well but let's just jump into kind of
the time frame and the process that's
going on right
now so I like to say that where we are
in the uh Gulf of main offshore W wind
leasing process is that we are at the
end of the
beginning so um the way that this works
is several years ago sen uh Governor
sonunu as well as some other Governors
requested a task force for the Gulf of
Maine to look at offshore wind that
stimulated bom the Bureau of ocean
Energy Management which is the federal
agency which leases out pieces of the
ocean uh for for energy stuff and so
they convene this task force the task
force includes lots of people many of
your constituents from communities
elected
officials and at that point that sort of
kicked off this process of beginning to
understand where leases might
go where we started on this process was
with pretty much the entirety of the
Gulf of Maine and where we are today is
that they just last Friday released the
actual wind energy areas which
incorporate um some millions of Acres of
ocean largely uh sort of the South I
would say South Central to South um
eastern part of the Gulf of Maine so if
you sort of picture uh coming off of
Cape Cod about 30 mil off of Cape Cod
and extending up about 50 miles from
there uh out in the ocean uh at its
closest point to New Hampshire that wind
energy area is about uh about 30 mil or
so offshore and at its most distant
place it's about 92 miles for those of
you who are are Tech Geeks which I don't
know at this committee seems like you
might want to have a couple um what that
means essentially for the Gulf of Maine
is that we're not going to be able to
have AC cable it's going to be it's
going to be DC cable so if you think
about that you know just from a DC we
can geek out here for just one second on
DC is that what that means is that
that's that's DC cable that has to be
created which is not readily available
there's basically one uh Factory in the
United States that makes DC and if you
looked at all the needs for DC cable
around the entire offshore uh what's
being sort of planned out in the world
right now um it would take something
like uh
990,000 uh person hours uh in order to
build the amount of DC cable that would
be required so I think that that just
sort of puts this in perspective that
there are some still some technological
issues um and the depth of the Gulf of
Maine would require all of these
facilities to be
floating uh again technology which is
now being employed throughout the world
there are several new uh offshore wind
uh floating technology uh basically
structures arrays uh and the first
commercial ones are just coming online
uh Portugal I believe is one and then
there's looking at southeast Asia is
going to be the other place where these
are going to be more common so that's
kind of the the sort of State of Affairs
as to where this is headed so the idea
with the bom leasing process is that
it'll establish this very long process
which includes lots and lots of public
input opportunities to go from the
entire Gulf of Maine down to a subset of
the Gulf of Maine uh which is what
released on Friday and I will send that
along to you after this so you can look
at those maps in detail on your own
computer because it's kind of fun to
explore that yeah go ahead jump in yeah
thanks I just want to be clear the um
the decision released on Friday was just
what areas are going to be leased the
leases themselves were not actually
assigned right so this is an area in
which there were there could be leases
within these areas so it's narrowed down
to just these wind energy areas where
there could be
leases what comes up next after this
will'll actually be establishing where
those lease areas are going to be and
what's actually going to be released for
lease how many leases they atttend to to
create how big each of those leases will
be
and all of the other you know autal that
goes along with the leasing process
which I'll talk a little bit more about
Henry yeah thank you uh with regards to
the leases how is how is the cable the
the length of the cable handle uh is it
is it treated as lease property or a
lease to to to to do or is yes that's
going to be delineated on the ground it
will not be this is a really good
question in one of the vexing this is
one of the most vexing pieces of the
process um and let me let me come back
to that question in a second let me sort
of kind talk about where we are where
we're headed if you have I think in
front of you you have a piece of paper
that looks something like this it says
oh it should be up on oh sorry I didn't
even see it there this slide
here that you see you see the star there
which shows that the wind energy areas
have been are now established those are
the final wind energy areas where we'll
be headed within the next 30 days or so
is that they will have a proposed lease
notice that proposed lease notice then
begins to get those actual lease areas
and it puts the language of the leases
out so there's a couple of things that
will happen with this within the lease
there'll be lease Provisions require
people to do certain things within those
leases as well as there will also be
bidding credits so bidding credits um
are are established to do um basically
it identifies particular things that
you're going to have to do if you want
to go go in on this bid so there's two
different aspects of this and we're
doing we're going to be doing an an
Outreach session for stakeholders in New
Hampshire on this process in about a
month and a half so that anyone who's
interested in understanding the ins and
outs of that will be able to have uh uh
we we'll have a session and I'll make
sure that you all are notified about
that because that's where this starts to
get really interesting um some of those
Provisions could be things like how are
you going to make sure that Fisheries
monitoring continues to take place uh
within your lease how are you going to
deal with safety issues how are you
going to deal with other issues and and
eventually we'll get around to trans
transmission but the idea within that is
that there'll be a number of Provisions
about what you can and can't do and and
money that you're going to have to pay
in order to do things like mitigation
um and making sure that you don't have
environmental impacts and what happens
if you do have environmental impacts
there'll be a whole series of Provisions
around that as well as things like your
financing and how you lock in your
financing and what do you have to show
at what point in the process all of that
and and then at some point you also have
to I think prove that you're you have a
market for your
electricity um which obviously New
Hampshire is not participating in that
activity that's we're not part of that
activity we don't do procurements here
but our surrounding states in Maine and
Massachusetts will be doing procurements
and so they may be um you know actually
having those those negotiations with
developers as they develop their
leases we'll be keeping close tabs on
that as well so the over the course of
60 days or so they'll have a public
comment period on this proposed sale
notific notice they'll then at some
point in the fall they will actually
hold the the lease off auction they'll
hold the lease auction they'll they'll
award those leases and those leases will
be issued by the end of this calendar
year so when I said we're sort of at the
end of the beginning this is bringing us
to the point at which you're launching
into somebody actually owns a
lease once they have that lease then
they have to start doing all of the
background work in order to understand
where you're actually going to put the
turbine
how many
turbines you know uh you're going to
have to have areas to be able to to get
ships through you have to identify where
your transmission cables are going to go
at that point where they're going to go
on land begin to have all of those
preparations that becomes part of your
constructions and operations plan all of
that will take probably out until
another five years or so to get through
and then there would be opportunities
for construction there'll be met Towers
they go up over time yes uh Mr chair do
developers have to start paying on those
leases as soon as they're signed my
understanding is that you pay some I'm
not sure if you pay all of it I think
you actually pay all of it like I think
you pay for the lease um so that's the
way it's worked in other places like in
the Gulf of Mexico they just did a lease
which was really uh there were very few
people who wanted to bid on that but
they did actually sell it it was like I
think it was like $4 million or
something but in New York bite when they
sold them they them for $500 million so
it's a big company with lots of
financing that can do that thank you yes
does all of this do the developers are
are they responsible for all of this leg
work that you're describing and you know
and what what role does the New
Hampshire office of offshore wind
development have great great questions
so
yes there's it's it's heavy on the
federal government because remember this
is in federal waters so they have
jurisdiction over all of this activity
because it's out in federal waters the
state does not have any jurisdiction at
this moment over what would happen out
in the Gulf of Maine Beyond three
nautical
miles the so so our role at this point
has really been to make sure that our
stakeholders who might be
impacted positively or negatively bu
this kind of activity have lots and lots
of information information and the other
thing that we've been doing is making
sure that we are well coordinated as a
state between Dees we are handling sort
of the offshore sighting stuff in
cooperation with fishing game fishing
game has a very strong role to play on
this for two things one is fisheries
habitat and the other is the people who
utilize Fisheries Habitat to make a
living so our fishing industry so so
we've been well coordinated with them
the office of energy and planning that
side is really much more sort of a a
comprehensive approach looking across
all of the agencies and really focused
on the energy side and I think you're
going to see a lot of uh activity in the
next weeks as ISO New England uh
releases a new kind of uh long-term plan
for for transmission when they release
that it's going to include some
conclusions that they've made about how
to plan for offshore wind and so that's
going to be really interesting to watch
because there's a lot of transmission
issues which we could do an entire
couple hours on transmission issues uh
related to this activity because it's
there's a lot going on there but I would
let our Brethren from from Department of
energy talk about that because they have
people that are qualified and then the
the uh Bea is also in uh in involved and
looking at Workforce uh development
training and making sure that there's um
that New Hampshire companies get their
chunk of the pie um as this
multi-billion dollar Investments begin
to get made uh offshore yeah you had a
question you mentioned that New
Hampshire is not doing any procurement
and our neighboring states are could you
could you explain why that is um I uh
that that happens at a uh way above my
pay grade um my understanding is that
that that in this state they they have
they we don't have like a renewable
portfolio sort of approach so other
states are required to to have some
portion of their electricity be a
certain amount this is what's Driven it
in Maine and Massachusetts is that they
have to come up with certain
renewable amounts of their electrical
load and the only way there is only one
way in which you can meet those goals
and the only way in which you can meet
those goals is to procure offshore so
that's why it's driving it in other uh
and again I'm not an electrical person
my understanding is that in New
Hampshire we have as much electricity as
we need um currently that's my
understanding but again I don't do this
for a living but that has not been the
the case in other states where they have
these these goals so that's what's
driving it at other places Ted can I
just yeah go so I would just add that a
lot some of our states near us have
statutory requirements in terms of zero
carbon emissions by specific dates and
that's what Ted's really alluding to
there to get there you need this type of
development right
so yeah so so over the next you know
basically eight years or so there'll be
a lot of process going on the developers
will be funding lots and lots of studies
um and then at some point they will
release they will get their their
construction and operation plan approved
and at that point they can begin
construction so as they say putting
steel in the water so down in
Massachusetts uh you you're probably
aware that they are starting to spin and
generate electrons and so that's now
going on to the grid the same thing is
going on in Virginia um and you'll see
you'll see that that over the next you
know over the next few years those those
very large wind arrays will come
online the only other thing I would
point out in terms of the leasing
process um is is that um uh state of
Maine also has a lease that they are
seeking for a research array which is
way up down almost down east uh Maine
and that will be an area in which
there'll be something like eight
turbines and it'll be a test facility uh
for understanding some of the unanswered
questions that currently exist with
floating technology such as you know how
do you deal with emfs from the
transmission cables is that a thing how
do you connect them uh from cable to
Cable how do you connect them to the
bottom what technologies are going to be
employed how do fish react to things
like offshore wind in the Gulf of Maine
those will be part of the research array
and that will be um there's there's a
significant effort in Maine to create
that sort of a facility uh and they're
working their way through this lease
process my guess is that will lease will
also be finalized by the end of the year
yes representative yeah it sounds like
so we're planning to do something that
has not been done
before
um I wouldn't say it hasn't been done it
hasn't been done at the scale of an
industrial scale and I think that that's
and certainly the you know North the
North Shore of Scotland is somewhat
different than the Gulf of Maine um
though both North Atlantic sort of
enviros um so yeah it is this is this is
at the bleeding edge of current
technologies that are employed but
they're not that different as I
understand it and again that's another
really fascinating uh the whole set
talking about the technology but as I
understand it it's not that different
from the technologies that are employed
currently for floating platforms for oil
and gas
exploration the size is a little
different the scale is a little
different the fact that it has a th foot
Tower uh sitting on the top with a giant
blade on it makes it a little different
uh but it's not that different um as I
understand it from a sort of technical
perspective ocean engineering
perspective from current very deep water
you know thousand foot depth uh oil and
gas uh you know exploration yeah is the
main pilot project also going to have
floating yes okay that was the that's
kind of the whole point is to make sure
that it reflects what will be the
reality in the Gulf of Maine so they'll
be moving along just I just have the
slide in there because it kind of talks
about what we've been doing as a state
to prepare our stakeholders for the
eventuality that we would have offshore
wind and I will say
the what we've been focusing on as a
state and we created a little group
called The stakeholder Outreach work
Group which we've got a agency
involvement from each of the
agencies is that it's been on process
process process because what this this
whole thing of getting these leases in
in place is a whole series of different
processes that all link together and so
what we've been doing is educating
stakeholders about the process so that
they can be involved and I say it's been
very successful the the letter that
eventually came out in terms of comments
from our New Hampshire uh commercial
Fisheries
Association it was highly influential
with a decision- making about where to
put these wind energy areas and that was
because I think to a great extent the
work that we've done over the years of
making sure that we had a really close
collaboration between our fishermen and
our government and so I'm really proud
of that and I'm really proud of where
We've Ended up in that process
just a couple of other places that I
would just note um doe the wind
development director is currently vacant
um and so that's a position that that
hopefully will get filled because that
does provide sort of that overarching
sort of keeping track of things as well
as the linkage back to energy itself and
so what we've done right now in the
absence of that is that we have our
group that we're coordinating I'm
spending a lot of time on this as is
Chris Elms who's their uh deputy
director
and so between us and between the staff
at the four different agencies uh I
think we have a pretty good coverage on
you know what's going on and and they've
been bringing their grid staff uh to
these meetings which has been really
helpful uh for the energy
side um Bea now has a person assigned
they had had a person and then that
person left so they now have a person
assigned uh to work on this so that's
really
great you're probably aware and maybe
some of you sit on the off Shore wind
commission uh that Senator Waters put
together a few years back that also has
been really helpful to be able to keep
coordinated across both agencies
localities and other parties such as the
labor unions uh and the Port Authority
all of that kind of hits together
because this touches lots of different
aspects of of Coastal
Life couple of other things I guess um
there was recently a report that was
done uh by Norm Associates in
partnership with another bunch of other
folks I can send that link around to you
all it's a really uh I think
comprehensive articulation of all the
sort of positives pluses and minuses the
pros and cons of offshore win two New
Hampshire how does it relate directly to
New Hampshire and I can send that around
it's very
comprehensive it's it's I think it's 500
pages or something like that but if if
you look at it a little bit at a time
especially if you're interested in
looking something up um it's actually
really helpful and there's a lot of
really good information in there so I'll
send that link around as well that was
completed last uh last
fall and then the last thing I would
note is that um there's a compensatory
mitigation uh requests for proposals out
on the street uh originally nine states
and now 11 states have joined together
to create a structure an administrator
for a compr for compensatory mitigation
dollars for Fisheries so assuming that
there's going to be fishering fishing
displaced by these turbines that they
won't be able to fish in some of those
areas making that assumption and that
that will have some economic impact on
both fishermen and the industry that
support them that that there there will
need to be compensatory mitigation for
those
folks um nobody likes to talk about this
because it's hard um because we don't
want those kinds of impacts and we're
trying to do all the minimization and
avoidances possible but it is possible
that there will be uh impacts over time
and so the developers will have to put
dollars into these compensatory
mitigation accounts and so what's being
developed right now is an RFQ to De to
develop an administrator that will serve
those this is largely being driven by
nerta that is the the the authority
within the the bite of new New York
that's doing all the wind work down
there they're at the point where they're
actually starting to get mitigation
dollars coming in the door and so
they're going to need an efficient and
effective way and the reason why the 11
states kind of came together to do this
is that we have people from New
Hampshire who fish off of the coast of
New Jersey people from New Jersey have
Co have have fishermen who who fish out
in Cash's ledge so we this is this is so
when we talk about the fishery there's
not a State fishery it is a regional
fishery and that's why this mitigation
is coming together so that's kind of the
goings on right now it's pretty exciting
time in the wind world uh and I can try
to answer any other questions you might
have John lewi has a question thank you
um has anybody had one of these floating
um platforms wind uh turbines anywhere
in the world where they got something
the equivalent of a North Atlantic
hurricane my understanding is that there
are some off the coast of the UK so
their weather you know I would imagine
is relatively brutal um but again um I
the these are some of the one of the
interesting things is that the country
of Norway uh is actually really
providing a lot of technical assistance
to the rest of the world on uh offshore
wind um and so they're positioning
themselves sort of to be able to do that
and so there's a partnership we've
actually have with Norway and if for
things like that if you're ever really
interested in that we can uh Identify
some some folks to for you to speak with
about you know kind of where the state
today representative Ms has a question
thank you um there a lot of different
New Hampshire agencies involved in this
in this process it's a big undertaking
complicated is there one agency that is
in charge like the the the go-to place
um the the the agency that's kind of you
know quarterbacking the whole effort
yeah so right now I think uh I would say
that because of the focus on up until
this point on
sighting that Dees has been extremely
involved in that process because it's
largely an offshore resource issue and
because we are because of our federal
consistency provisions of the federal of
the the coastal zone management act
which is a federal act we play a very
strong role in that process as do our
other Coastal States and so we work very
closely with those other states on that
offshore sighting as well as with fish
and game so today in the process because
the process is so driven on offshore
information and resources Dees has
largely led the effort for the state at
some point pretty
soon this is be going to become much
more of an energy thing and as that
starts to occur then I think that you'll
see that office of offshore uh develop
offshore wind development I can't
remember what they call it now um that
that office will become probably more
key in some of this so but I would just
say that at this point the interaction
between the state has between the state
agencies has been rather
seamless so we've been working very very
very closely and we are aware of what
each other is
doing so if you want to know what's
going on if you want to go to somebody
you can come to me or you can come to
Chris Elms because right now we're
that representative Reynolds has a
question thank you Mr chairman um not
withstanding all the all the talk here
including your presence of course of
course uh all the talk about all the
government agencies federal government
state government coordination in this
process of the development of offshore
wind
energy isn't it true that ultimately the
parties that are going to build and
operate the offshore turbin and the
transmission lines that connect them to
the grid isn't that going to be private
entities isn't that private Capital
investing in this energy resource
absolutely yeah okay thanks just wanted
to
clarify okay thank you very much thank
you well thank you Ted that was
fascinating only took him a half hour to
do two slides so at that pace I hope
you're all had dinner too just I'm just
kidding so I'll ask Mike to come back up
and join me Mike and I are going to tag
team a base presentation that we
actually gave to you folks a little over
a year ago in January of 2023 we're not
going to hit every talking point we want
to keep this kind of moving along but
feel free to raise your hand slow us
down if you want us to clarify something
so first I would just introduce the
division's leadership team here on this
slide here um I would encourage anybody
to reach out to any one of these folks
with any question if they can't answer
it they're going to find somebody that
can answer the question for you by my
calculation this group has about 150
years of service uh to the state of New
Hampshire at the department so uh very
seasoned group here so
Mike so this is just an organizational
chart of the air Resources Division um
I'm not going to run through everything
here but it gives you by what each one
of these groups do on a daily basis
where their areas of expertise are what
parts of the laws they implement
um we're going to hit on them a little
bit later on so again I'm not going to
go into this the only thing I'll point
out is the director's office to the
frite we don't consider that a bureau
obviously um but we do more than just
division management and budgeting we
have some technical programs uh in the
director's office as all as well and
we're going to talk about those as well
I am just going to point out the Small
Business technical assistance program on
the bottom right here uh that's Sarah
Johnson that's a federal cleaner act
required program it was in the
commissioner office until last year and
then it moved back to the air Resources
Division so we're very happy to have
Sarah back working for us and she
provides free service the small
businesses trying to understand very
regulations just as an overview um the
air Resources Division not only
implements state laws we implement the
vast majority of federal Clean Air Act
laws including monitoring for air
pollution developing and maintaining
strategies to make sure that we meet
those air quality standards that's our
job one is to make sure that New
Hampshire meets those Federal air
quality standards it's very important to
us from a public health standpoint is
very important to us from a business
standpoint um we currently have 38
chapters of administrative rules we've
adopted hundreds of federal new source
performance standards KNE shaps those
are federal hazards they are pollutant
standards and Mission guidelines these
are largely Federal standards related to
Smoke Stack indust indries uh we think
it's in everybody's best interest that
New Hampshire have authority over those
programs so we take delegation by of all
those programs um Ard Staffing we have
71 full-time positions currently around
10 vacancies I think that's the lowest
it's been in the last five years so I'm
actually pleased that we're getting to
that point where we're getting fully
staffed again lot of Engineers um
environmental Life Sciences atmospheric
science types just a lot of technical
science and uh back ground as far as the
agency we have a couple attorneys that
work on our rules and that work in our
compliance group as
well again I won't run through all these
um we implement or responsible for a
number of State statutes they're all
listed here the ones I would point out
that generally are the biggest players
for us are RSA 125c that's our general
Authority that's where we get our
authority to run our air permit programs
our enforcement programs General
rulemaking Authority um I would also
point out our a 125i that's a kind of a
unique program the state does have an
air toxics uh control program we set
health-based standards for over 600
compounds that regulated sources need to
demonstrate compliance of with I'll also
point out RSA 125 that's where we run
our Reggie program that's duly run by us
and uh the department of energy although
Dees does most of the technical work uh
doe deals with the money side primarily
uh the last program I'll mention is just
141e asbest we Implement two Federal
asbest programs here at the state and
they're in the air Resources Division
one is the demolition renovation of
existing structures and how you manage
ASB best us and get that out before you
do that that work and then we also uh
implement the federal what we call a her
program which is as bestest in schools
program there are a number of schools in
New Hampshire that have as bestus
generally the thought process is you're
better to leave it in place and properly
manage it um than it is to remove it
so as a Air Pollution Control agency one
thing we know is that air pollution
Knows No geopolitical Boundaries so we
play in a lot of clubs across the
country that deal with Air Pollution
Control issues we know on some of our
worst air quality days the vast majority
of pollution in New Hampshire is
transported into New Hampshire from out
of state uh up wind sources um so we
work on a number of multi state
organizations probably the one we deal
the most with is nescom northeast states
coordinated air use management that's
the six New England states New York New
Jersey lot of success stories there on
developing programs uh across multi
multi-jurisdictional States I do serve
on the board of directors of nescom as
do my counterparts across uh New England
New York and New Jersey so um we we we
get a big saying what goes on there so
uh the only other one I'll point out
here is the ozone ozone transport
commission this is the clean act
developed uh program it actually
recognizes the fact that no single state
is going to deal with ozone pollution it
is you need to deal with it on a
regional basis this group covers all the
states from Maine all the way down to
Virginia and we're very active on the
OTC level uh and the commissioner at
Dees serves on the board of directors
for the OTC
so state agencies we interact with I
can't even name all these state agencies
but suffice it to say we're very active
we have I believe we extremely good
working relationships with all of these
agencies uh we work with them on various
different types of uh things that are
related across program um so we're very
pleased with our uh the way we work with
these folks and uh they know how to
reach us and we know how to reach them
one thing beautiful about New Hampshire
is that we are a small state relatively
speaking and I think the interaction
agency not only within the department
but across state government is pretty
good from what from what I can tell from
counterparts financially um we have
about just under a $14 million operating
budget um we're very dependent on fees
almost half of our Revenue comes from
fees that's either stationary sources
folks that we permit espb bestus fee and
a very small amount of Motor Vehicle
fees uh we're also very reliant on
federal grants uh that's the yellow part
that's almost
38% uh our challenges with the Federal
Grant is the our base grants have been
level funded for probably 10 15 20 years
what I buy today for a dollar isn't what
I used to buy so it it's been a
challenge in managing uh those federal
grants I also just like to point out uh
General funds the air division of those
71 positions only four of them are
General funds here's half of it right
here myself and Mike uh so if you're
looking for cuts you can start there
probably
of and then uh we have two other
positions and actually John patali
behind me is one of those other
positions and Mary buto in our
environmental health program so um I the
next slide I think is a really important
message it it it it I not sure if people
understand this totally but maintaining
good air quality we think is important
not only for the environment but the
economy as well um one of the most
important things I talked about was it's
our job to make sure sure we meet those
Federal air quality standards right now
we meet all those Federal air quality
standards but if we don't meet those
Federal air quality standards that's
where it becomes an economic impact in
New Hampshire because we are forced into
developing additional regulations to
lower emissions and that has a potential
impact across the economy of course
we're a public health program first and
foremost uh clean air helps to decrease
health care costs I like to say New
Hampshire is a beautiful state I think
we all agree with that I think clean air
is a good part of that clean air
supports our forests our forests support
our clean rivers and clean Lakes so to
me it's all intertwined into an
so again I'll just mention this it's
epa's responsibility under the Clean Air
Act to set what we call these National
ambient air quality standards there's a
number of pollutants listed here that we
have standards for um EPA is required to
review those standards every five years
under the Clean Air Act they don't
always meet that schedule
um they do a very scientific approach to
establishing what these standards need
to be um and they also um like I said uh
they supposed to look at them every five
years I've never known them to go up
I've only only known them to get more
stringent over time as science gets
better as better understanding of how
air pollution impacts the human body
these standards tend to get tighter over
time and I think we got a graph coming
up that will show
that again the most important thing is
meeting that Federal Airbase standard I
think oh sorry this is the right order
so um we use the term attainment
non-attainment attainment means we meet
the standard non-attainment means we
don't meet that standard again the
important thing we're currently
attainment we need to stay in attainment
that's our goal Mike uses a great
analogy all the time he talks about when
you're dieting and you get to your goal
weight you can't go back to what you
were doing before and eating
cheeseburgers and pizza every night
right you need to maintain the level of
effort
that's a very important thing that's
essentially largely where New Hampshire
is in terms of the federal standards is
we're in the a maintenance mode you know
we need to keep the gains that we've
already made and I see a question
right thank you d uh so last year when
we had the uh the forest fires up in
Canada did we go into non-attainment or
we were skimming above it or so whether
you're in attainment or not attainment
it it depends on on the pollutant uh
there's different averaging times
there's different ways they calculate
attainment non attainment um what we had
in those situations where several days
where we exceeded the standards we
certainly were above the health-based
standards for PM especially in the Keen
area and a few other parts of the states
but the numbers weren't high enough to
push us into non- attainment yet so
because it's basically a three-year
average of the highs of the fourth high
so there's a mathema iCal formula so it
pushed our number up but didn't put us
into that situation yet so the other
thing with well the new P PM 2.5
standard uh cause attainment problems or
non- attainment problems I actually
meant to put a slide in here right now
we believe we still have to complete the
basis of that is going to be 2022 2023
and 2024 so we need to get through 2024
to know for sure but right now we would
still meet that new proposed Federal
standard so uh the other thing we can
say about wood smoke just real real
quick uh that's what could be an
exceptional event if those events were
to push us into non attainment New
Hampshire could seek to take those
numbers out of our attainment status
calculation simply because there's
nothing we can do about that that's a
so uh savings Clause that's the no
backsliding um that's that's where the
diet analogy comes in um you know we're
we're largely in that mode um if we
don't maintain we we potentially subject
New Hampshire to um sanctions those
sanctions could either be in federal
grants potentially Highway funds or
require more stringent permanent
requirements for our regulated
Industries so we don't want to get there
either uh air quality measurements this
is about 60% of where we spend our
federal money federal grants we get um
we operate 13 sites across the state
literally from the top of Mount
Washington down the Connecticut River
Valley across the Southern Tier the Sea
Coast up the marac river valley and we
have one monitor in lonia which is
obviously a very popular place in the
summertime so we like to uh monitor
there on the left lists the pollutants
we monitor for we don't monitor for
every pollutant at every station we just
don't have that capability nor the
resources to do that so we're very
strategic and we work with EPA on an
annual basis and on a 5-year review
cycle uh to talk about what we're going
to monitor for and where we're going to
monitor for
so
y yes go ahead thanks would it be
possible for you to just provide us or
have maybe give us reference later to a
matrix of
the stations yep we have and which
station monitor do they monitor you know
on the Sea Coast do we monitor for
everything do we monitor for two we have
a chart that we can make available which
identify each site and what pollutant is
monitored for at that site and Mike's
note representative Corman yeah just
looking at the map I mean I see uh
stations in Portsmith and Ry which are
awfully close together and then nothing
north of Mount Washington so couple
great points you can read a map very
well so Portsmith and Ry uh we monitor
ozone at both of those sites and and we
purposely put two monitors relatively
close together there for ozone because
ozone has a very unique interaction with
a where there's a water land interface
and seab breezes and on offshore breezes
and all that stuff so it's very
scientific that we we will often pick up
something in Rye but not see it in
psmith and they're only separated by
less than a mile so we did that
purposefully
uh with respect to Northern New
Hampshire um actually last Summer's
wildfires made it very abundantly clear
to us that one thing we don't have in
the North country is a fine particulate
monitor which would be an indicator of
wood smoke so we are actually just
recently got a a grant from EPA that we
intend to put a new PM monitor up north
whether we include ozone or anything
else like that we don't know yet at this
point so we did put a temporary monitor
up last year as well
yeah
Henry thank you Mr chairman uh it used
to be when the mill was running in
Berlin you you would get readings from
the mill correct do that with other
locations other Mill locations um
project anything else in the North
Country the we we definitely used to
have several monitors up in the Berlin
area I think sulfur dioxide was one and
carbon monoxide was another um they were
specifically there to monitor air
quality related to air emissions from
the mill um probably the only only other
site we have in the state that's
specifically located for the probably
the purposes of monitoring a source
would be the PM Brook site which is
downwind of marac station and we monitor
for SO2 there which is the primary
pollutant of concern coming out of
marac and the next slide these are just
some pictures of our monitoring sites
these are all stick figures uh kind of
you you know these are probably 8 by1
sheds um they all probably contain you
know hundreds of thousands of dollars of
air monitoring equipment um we have
field technicians that visit them on a
regular basis one of the things we've
really invested in late in the last five
to 10 years is because we don't get more
Federal money we need to streamline
operations so a lot of this stuff is now
automated so it requires less you know
visits from a technician but we still do
need to go out there and actually all of
our air quality monitoring data from all
of these sites is on the dees website
and it's only an hour old so you can get
an update every hour as to what the air
quality is across the state of New
Hampshire
so the uh Miller State Park is a great
one to visit if you're interested that's
at the top of Pacman adock um and uh
it's a great hike and well worth the
visit but also I just a note that we
have one of these stations in our
parking lot at Hazen drive if anyone
wanted to come over and take a look and
see see how we operate what we do there
we'd be happy to show you we'd also be
happy to have you accompany us to Miller
Washington so uh mentioned these are
like 8x1 10 x 12 structures uh we're
currently putting a new monitor in lonia
using some real Advanced Micro shelter
techniques so we're going from a
footprint of 80 to 100 square foot site
to probably something that's 3 by three
and a half so it's a much smaller
footprint monitoring site which we think
is going to save us a lot of money on an
operational standpoint because think of
the heating and cooling loads on these
structures it's a much smaller footprint
so we're excited to be working on that
i' also just mentioned the site in
London area that you see there is what's
called an incor site um it's a it's a
very highly technical site and it's also
an educational site for us it's located
at us the musil school in londondary and
uh you know uh we we have educational
information for students and so on there
um and uh we we are one of just a few
states that have two of these endc cor
sites we have
uh the one at Miller and and the one in
London Derry and U they they provide us
with a significant amount of good
science as well as um air monitoring so
uh if you're in the vicinity it's well
worth uh taking a taking a stop
by all right so the next slide just
talks about General air quality issues
in New Hampshire uh historically ozone
in the summer has been our largest
regulatory driver um we again we're
currently a tment for we still have
probably a handful of days every year
where we exceed the ozone standard uh at
least in the Sea Coast Area sometimes
across the state um find particular
matter traditionally that's been more of
a wintertime pollutant uh a lot of it
related to uh localized wood burning uh
during the winter months heating season
I always say wood is good so don't don't
get me wrong by saying singling out wood
here I I do believe in burning wood um
just need to burn the right wood and the
right device so um you to be like I said
a wintertime thing we have noticed the
last couple years more and more
incidents of Canadian wildfires I just
read an article this week uh that um
there's still hundreds of fires burning
underground in Canada they coined the
term zombie fires so we're we're
watching
that Yep they're expecting uh another
dry winter across Northern Canada so we
are expecting uh wood smoke issues again
potentially in New Hampshire last last
year was at levels that we had never
seen we didn't quite get it here in New
Hampshire but we all saw pictures of
what was going on in New York City and
Pennsylvania those were levels of air
pollution that we've never dealt with
here in New Hampshire I mean there's six
levels on our scale typically we get to
level three or four but we don't usually
get to five or six so last summer we
spent time working with Department of
Public Health Services to come up with
an action plan if we were to see those
extremely high levels and we plan on
dusting that plan off this year again in
preparation for the season coming
up uh Regional Haze I'm just going to
quickly mention uh we have to reach New
Hampshire has two class one areas those
are special areas under the Clean Air
Act they receive special protections and
one of them is visibility uh we have to
reach what they call Natural background
conditions by
2064 so I'm pretty sure I'll be long
gone by then so I'm going to leave that
to the to the stat now just kidding we
are currently in our second planning
period uh for regional Haze we've
actually made good progress as a state
in the region in improving Regional uh
Haze and visibility in the class one
areas it's kind of flattened out the
last year or so so we're monitoring that
and we'll continue to to make
strides from a very high level people
ask how is the air quality in New
Hampshire I think this this table here
summarizes about as good as you can do
this is all of our counties and our high
elevation sites on the far right high
elevation being uh Mount Washington and
Pacman adok green represents good
qualities in good air quality in the
state and you can see most days we're
generally uh 80 to 90% of the time we're
good air quality 10% of the time we're
moderate air quality and then a handful
of times we get to that unhealthy for
sensitive groups and that's when we're
standards this is another nice chart
that shows ozone Trends in New Hampshire
uh the red line here is really something
that I want to point out we mentioned
that EPA does the periodic review of the
standards and that red line represents
how EPA has revised the standard over
time um as you can see it always goes
down it never goes up um but if you also
look at the data uh we've seen
tremendous emission reductions across
New Hampshire and across the country as
a whole um under the Clean Air Act and
state statutes um and as you can see as
a result of that our air quality has
improved and that's the black line it
shows how you can see there were periods
in the past where we're above those
standards but now we're below all those
standards so that that's a good
long-term Trend and that's one we want
to continue cuz I suspect this standard
will get more stringent in the future
yes uh what's the main source of ground
level ozone so ozone is a
soup it's a chemical reaction that is
combines um oxygen nitrogen
B it it comes it comes primarily well
there's naturally occurring ozone of
course both in the upper atmosphere and
lower atmosphere but in terms of
man-made ozone It's a combination of
emissions of nitrogen oxides volto
organic compounds and the presence of
sunlight and it's a it's a chemical
reaction oh it's it's primarily from
caruse regulated Smoke Stack Industries
it's it's from us burning fuel at home
it's from Transportation it's from power
plants it's from coating operations
so coding
yep the issue with ozone is that a lot
of the pollutants that form ozone are
transported um and they come up the 95
Corridor the mobile Source portion of it
but also that's the prevailing wind
pattern that you know if you look if you
want to know what our weather is look
out in the midwest a couple days ago so
we get emissions from power plants in
the midwest that come come this way
combine and then and then when they come
in to New Hampshire they mix with our
emissions and then the sunlight so the
ozone can actually form here but the
pollutants that create it are
transported in and sometimes it's
created elsewhere and transported in
that's and that's the issue we see at
Rye also with the uh uh onshore breezes
ozone goes out over the ocean and then
comes back in representative Noel did
you have a
question oh
okay all right uh okay uh just quickly
our air pering program um in New
Hampshire we're a fully delegated State
uh EPA has approved our state's Minos
Source permitting program and also
they've delegated as authority of the
federal Title 5 permit program which is
for major sources um we like to we again
we think that's a good thing for New
Hampshire Industries uh if you need an
air permit whether it's a state or a
federal ebased permit you come to New
Hampshire Dees there is a role for EPA
and I think one of the other slides
talks about that overall we have about
uh I think six or 700 sources that have
air permits in New Hampshire we receive
about 120 applications a year um we have
400 or so sources permited we have a
what we call a general State permit um
this is something we'd like to actually
expand our ability to do where we
establish a single permit and sources
can register under that General permit
rather than um get a site specific
permit and that is a uh fully online
that again New Hampshire Dees is where
the lead on the federal Title 5 permit
program there is a role for EPA EPA has
the ability to review comment on draft
decisions authority to object to a a
permit as far as I can recall since
we've had this program a 1993 EPA has
never formally objected to all of any of
our permits um there was a couple issues
a number of years ago on One Source but
we dealt with that
uh EPA audits our Title Five permit
program every five years um my
understanding from Reading their audit
the last go go around is that we got a
very clean bill of health from EPA in
terms of how we run our titley permit
program and then the only other thing
I'll say about permits in general is any
decision we make can be appealed to the
a Resources Council it's a separate
oversight board uh established under
separate RSA and if if either uh a party
a private party or the the company is
unhappy with a permit decision there's a
process they can follow to appeal to the
air Resources Council representative
Thomas has a question thank you um just
with regard to air permits did the EPA
review the most recent air permit for S
go Bay and marac we send all of our
permits to EPA um for state permits like
St gobain they don't have a formal role
uh like the title fire permit program
there's definitely a formal role for EPA
uh we send all of our permits to them
whether they choose to comment on a
state only permit uh you know that's
obviously up to
them but yes it was sent to
them I don't believe they
commented I just wanted to mention with
regards to permits also this year we
have uh requested one piece of
legislation which is started over in the
Senate
s449 that adjusts some timelines for us
to correct um uh and allow us to be uh
uh comport with with the federal
requirements and and um that did pass
out of the senate committee last week
and it'll hope I assume it'll be coming
to this committee uh sometime in the
next few weeks um and we' certainly it's
a request of Dees and uh it's it's to
allow us to have the appropriate
timelines um and it's really it's really
uh I won't say a recordkeeping but it's
it's very much a housekeeping type of
thing that we need to straighten out
hope you're uh we'll give it some
consideration when it comes
across uh what we we can jump to the
next slide I
think so just our compliance Bureau
these are the boots on the ground these
are the folks out in the field
inspecting sources um these are the the
folks that are out in the field when
there is an emissions test required in
New Hampshire out of a smoke stack uh
our policy is to be on site to oversee
the stack testing we don't do the
testing but we review the protocols for
the test we're on site to oversee the
testing to make sure it's done in
accordance with Federal testing
requirements and we review the final
reports as well so we think that's an
important part of that program um we
probably are out there 80 to 100 tests a
year um complaints we get about 70 to 80
we try to investigate every single
complaint on some level sometimes it's a
phone call to this to a situation to
understand it better sometimes it's
where we send an inspector out to see
what's going on out there our esus
Management program uh I mentioned that
we do two things we do the asbest in
school the aara program we do 30 to 40
inspections a year um at schools that
contain as bestus to make sure they're
complying with the federal or heer
requirements and we also oversee we get
somewhere in the neighborhood of 1,200
notifications a year for demolition
renovation projects where there's aestus
being removed uh we get out and probably
inspect 10 to 15% of those I I wish
somebody would say can you do more but
that's what we have the resources to do
so um what else we got uh enforcement
actions not our first choice obviously
we want to work with industry to make
sure they're in compliance uh but we
have a number of tools in terms of
enforcement in ter including the ability
to issue letters of deficiencies uh uh
put on administrative fines or refer
things to the Attorney General's office
for civil penalties our goal with
respect to enforcement is to have a
source get into compliance first and
foremost and then deal with the
non-compliance issue after that and then
our other goal is to handle all cases
right here in New Hampshire and have EPA
not over file on any enforcement actions
and I am not aware of EPA over filing in
any any recent action we've taken you
have an idea of roughly how many per
year enforcement actions it really
varies year toe we actually put together
an annual report on our enforcement
actions it can be anywhere from 20 a
year to 100 so we could certainly make
that report available to the committee
if you'd
like there's also a very wide variety of
enforcement actions be some things can
be very minor recordkeeping issues and
others are so num actual numbers of
actions doesn't correlate to
severity representative
bernardy thank you Mr chair uh just
going back to asbest you say around
1,200 a year is that trending down as as
hopefully we're getting rid of it most
of it in the state you know that's what
we expect but we just haven't seen that
yet um there's a lot of Redevelopment
going on in New Hampshire a lot of old
buildings Old Mill buildings a lot of
old structures and a lot of that work's
being done you would think eventually it
would work its way out yeah you would
think so but long-term trends we're not
yet representative Noel thank you Mr
chairman uh in general with regards to
the compliance and the Staffing that you
have do you feel you're you're you're
seeing the majority of the issues that
are out there or do you feel that
there's still a lot of things not being
picked up in your compliance efforts I I
I I think we run a very comprehensive
program um especially with respect to
our permanent sources we have a lot of
regulatory oversight on permanent
sources um either through a mandatory
inspection schedule that EPA sets and we
comply with um complaints were fairly
good at
um following up on um it's the things we
don't know about that you know if
somebody doesn't report it to us or if
we don't see it or if we're not there um
but I I would say generally in New
Hampshire we have a high level of
compliance in our regulated
Industries I'd also note that we're one
of very few states that actually
observes and uh overseas every stack
test um very few States have uh have
that
requirement I think Mike were you gonna
pick it up from here
okay you mean pick it up speed wise
or well we've only gone a half
hour but we can pick it up no um so
again uh big mentioned one of our
bureaus is our Technical Services Bureau
that oversees the air monitoring program
that we oh I'm sorry that oversees the
air monitoring program that we've
already talked about um we deal with mob
sources uh again Vehicles vehicular
traffic and so on that's a very tough
tough nut to crack that's you know
hitting people where they live and and
drive so on and um um so uh we do have a
role in Regional Transportation Planning
um we do Implement along with the
Department of Safety the federal Clean
Air Act required vehicle inspection
maintenance program um we have some
voluntary programs uh we also receive
federal funding under the the um diesel
emission reduction act for replacing
diesel uh older diesel vehicles with
with newer engines and um and and also
we oversee the Volkswagen settlement
that um uh put $30 million into the
state of New Hampshire um we oversee the
dispersement of those funds uh for
replacement of engines and that that
type of work um 15% of that can be used
for implementing EV infrastructure
and we've been we've been uh
establishing uh some some new EV sites
in the state of New Hampshire as well um
we also have energy and climate programs
we defer primarily to the Department of
energy on energy issues um up until you
know we didn't have a department of
energy until a couple of years ago and a
few years ago so um but now now that we
do um on the energy side we defer to
them primarily on the financial issues
um on environmental issues we we will
raise issues and make sure that there's
um uh you know the environmental
requirements are met um we also
Implement I'll talk later about the
regional greenhouse gas initiative um we
were the agency that actually um brought
the RPS to the state but again that's
primarily run by Doe now because it
really is an energy Market um and um uh
esek is uh State uh state agencies the
organization of state agencies that um
we work together to reduce reduce energy
usage and and lower costs for state
agencies uh and um then uh we do uh to
we work closely with both doe and pu um
as environmental issues effect there was
so again mobile sources um I've talked
about yeah sorry can't do two things at
once um I've talked about these uh these
issues here so I think I'll
um
can't why can't keep my so yeah again uh
Dr and VW we've talked about um we in
the director's office we also have an
atmospheric science and Analysis group
that um does does our modeling work and
a lot of them we we do model um St stary
sources before they get a permit for
toxics and and other other pollutants um
we uh do maintain what's known as an
emissions inventory we determine uh uh
the total amount of pollutants that are
emitted in New Hampshire we do estimates
of of a lot of different pollutants uh
and and maintain that inventory uh as
Craig mentioned we participate in the
OTC and Main view main view is um
Mid-Atlantic Northeast visibility Union
that's the regional Haze issue that
Craig talked about that's the
organization of states that that work on
that because that Regional Haze again is
transported up the uh up up the coast
from a number of sources so um the uh
Pam's monitoring is the highly
sophisticated Inc Court uh sites that we
uh we do um that's a highly scientific
uh pams as a component of ozone and so
uh we we measure that we are also put
put out daily air pollution forecasts
that the TV stations all pick up and and
are in newspapers and so on um uh every
especially on days where there's air
quality impairment those few days that
Craig mentioned in the other slide and
we have the citizens air monitoring
program which where citizens can
actually buy their own little sensors
and uh enroll them with us and and
measure uh PM pollution so number of
questions seem to be representative
Thomas thank you Mr chair um with regard
to the measuring of past compounds can
you tell me how many compounds you
you're looking for are they just the
four that are
regulated uh as far as regulatory
monitoring yes we have done we've we've
done some stack testing and we have a
lot of data on other compounds but um
from a regulatory standpoint the only
thing that the statute uh uh gives us
authority over is those four compounds
that uh have impacted water uh in in the
in the area but we do have we do collect
a lot of data on numerous other
compounds and have collected it over the
years especially in regards to S our
requirements with the SLE bean stack
tests thank you representative
Corman representative
Noel thank you Mr chair uh in in the
interest of General air quality does
anybody in your department monitored for
CO2 CO2 level uh uh no CO2 is a is a
pollutant related to uh you know it's a
greenhouse gas obviously and so on um
but it's it doesn't have direct uh
impacts like the six pollutants that we
we did and also CO2 uh is a very general
pollutant um and so a measurement in a a
specific area is really not overly
informative
CO2 in the atmosphere tends to disperse
and it has a pretty General level and
it's that General in the atmosphere
that's a that's a a problem and and
creates the uh uh climate issues that
were we address but we don't measure it
directly I know there is one station in
Hawaii and I might have to go
investigate that
uh some some point I think CO2 is
uniform everywhere on Earth pretty
pretty much yes yes there represent
partial yes I assume you'd say the same
thing if I asked about methane correct
yeah yeah well uh the biggest methane
issue is is oil and gas operations and
Le leaking and EPA has done a lot of
work over the last couple of years and
so on we don't have a lot of of oil and
gas pipelines um here in New Hampshire I
mean there are other there there are
different sources of methane but um
that's that's that's the biggest issue
and and but it's also a greenhouse gas
pollutant
neither Craig or I understand this slide
but no no this just kind of shows we we
have a unit in in the director's office
called the state implementation plan the
uh unit sip for short um the way that
EPA oversees us is by What's called the
state implementation plan when there's
an EPA requirement we we adopt that
requirement we put it into our Sip and
so this just shows that that sip unit
net Works to marry Federal requirements
the state requirements and um a num
numerous others uh to they those those
go into our Sip and our planning um
group and um there's a lot of overlap u
a huge issue for us nowadays is 91a
requests as you know state every state
agency um so we we get a lot of requests
for that this is the same unit that also
develops our rules for us um Craig
mention men we have uh 38 chapters of
rules I think um I do want to make a
quick point about rules because we've
gotten a lot of questions this year
there seems to be a
misconception um all of our rules are
adopted pursuant to statute and and
every one of those rules is um passed
through uh and approved by jail car uh
so um we don't just go out and adopt
rules for the heck of it we uh every one
of our rules has a statutory basis and
um uh again again they go through jail
car for approval so um we've got a
number of inquiries this this year from
legislators about why did you adopt this
rule why you know Etc and do you have
any legal authority to do that well we
we do and that Authority comes from
statute and that statute comes from this
um Regional greenhouse gas program we
can spend a lot of time on that
basically it's a coalition of northeast
states that uh regulate CO2 emissions
from power plants and um uh you can see
there's uh from time to time States New
Jersey was in originally came out went
back in uh Pennsylvania and Virginia are
are going through different um
considerations right now so on so this
chart will actually change this year um
as different states come in and out of
the
program and the way the program works
basically is uh it it regulates uh any
power plant any fossil fuel power plant
that uh is 25 megawatts or greater in
size and we identify the emissions from
those we set an emissions cap uh that's
a regional cap it's not a per state uh
cap uh each state then issues allowances
for the emissions that come from its
power plants um in New Hampshire we have
several sources including the marac
station plant the plant in London Dair
the plant in Newington um there
uh you know the shill plant used to be
uh one that's that's closed down now um
but uh we uh issue allowances for those
sources to operate and then the number
of allowances the allowance cap goes
down over time and sources have to
purchase these allowances in order to to
Emit and so that's they they work to
lower their emissions and that program's
been in place since roughly
2009 and uh also goes through uh reviews
every few years we're in the process of
working with the other states right now
to uh to review it and determine um if
there are changes that should be made to
that program but that program is in
sconed in statute um uh RSA
1225 and if we want to change that we
need to come to you and get the uh get
the approval of the legislature to make
that any statutory changes to that
program so anything that we work with
the other states on implementing we
can't just agree and say oh yeah we'll
do that we have to come bring it back
here you agree then we have the then
then we'll work with the other states to
implement um another area that we uh
have in the air division is our
environmental health program this
program uh goes across all the divisions
um does a lot of work uh on uh uh
environmental health issues
education uh and um also so when we get
receive uh concerns uh issues like PS in
in miramac and so on um we have staff
that look look into those they help us
develop standards um give us an
environmental uh a health basis and a
scientific basis for for a lot of the
work that we do and you'll hear a little
bit few minutes from um Dr John patali
who's in in this group uh uh relative to
uh PF Health standards that was one of
the questions that was uh asked of us so
uh and and we do work with other state
agencies as well
um so relative to pest very quickly uh
you all are aware that several years ago
St gobain um provided information to De
that um uh significant emissions that
had come from that plant and those
emissions uh resulted in uh groundwater
contamination this is one of the few
pollutants that actually goes into the
air is deposited on the ground and then
gets into groundwater and it created a
very significant groundwater problem um
and so uh we worked with st gobain um to
first of all we worked with the
legislature to develop um a statute that
required uh emissions controls because
this was an area that we just didn't
have uh strong uh requirements on other
than under area toxics requirement uh we
worked closely with st gobain we
uh measured their emissions we did Stack
testing we required them to do stack
testing um we actually worked with EPA
to establish the requirements for these
stack tests so that we did did uh
address a wide variety of p pasas is as
Greg mentioned with ozone it's a soup
it's it's hundreds of compounds
literally so um uh New Hampshire has
four that are are uh the way that the
New Hampshire statute works is if we
adopt a water standard then the water
standard requires that the air emissions
be evaluated as as well and we have four
that we have water standards for um so
this is a pollutant that actually works
backwards from water to the air to the
Smoke Stack and then to the control to
controls uh and uh that's a very unusual
situation we're currently doing Ru
making under the uh uh statute that was
established in
2016 and uh again we've focused very
very closely our major issue with pasas
is obviously the St gobain facility
which has announced their closing um and
uh but they have installed controls that
were all directed by us um uh a
regenerative thermal oxidizer to uh
lower their p p emissions tremendously
and um uh that was all done uh through
our uh through our permitting and under
the requirements of the uh RSA
125 uh that were
established so again the legislation s
SP 309 in 2018 um gave us the authority
to deal with these pollutants um we've
we established the standards and
required the uh uh emissions controls at
s go Bane and now we're working on rules
that would affect any other sources that
came into New Hampshire or that might
change their uh processes and
potentially emit any FAS um and we're in
the process of going through that rul
I think
I um so uh yeah also that legislation
did create um Dr Pat's p position and uh
it required us to develop a plan for um
for developing surface water quality
standards that would then further uh uh
further address different past compounds
and um so using that general fund
appropriation we were able to hire a
couple of staff and including Dr patali
and um requires us to do uh reviews
every five years of the uh uh P
pollutants to determine if other aqs are
necessary representative Thomas thank
you Mr chair um taking my mask off for
this one so you can hear me um I'm
wondering if you can comment on the
efficacy of monitored natural
attenuation Mna as a mediation strategy
specifically for past chemicals I would
prefer you have ke kept your mask on so
I couldn't because I I that's not an an
area that I'm certainly familiar with
but perhaps Dr patelli does that have
any
so you're you're next on the slide
anyway thank thank you thank you for
out
so that's something that I would also
still to defer over to the waste
management divis division so I know Mike
whimet at the recent pest commission
discussed that issue about natural
attenuation and where that plays into
remediation plans depending on what
technology is available and feasible and
what media is being assessed for
mediation so ultimately I would still
defer out to them yes followup followup
um I'll for those who are not familiar
with m& it it is simply waiting for
these chemicals to degrade these are
however forever chemicals that do not
degrade so how can that be considered an
Avenue of
remediation again you'd have to ask some
of the engineers about that with a lot
of other we call them recalcitrant
chemicals that stick around for a long
time if we don't have the technology to
break them down and we can't move them
from a
site that's pretty much the option
that's left so if you don't have any
technology to fix it and you don't want
to move it and make it another communi
problem we run into that with a lot of
organic
contaminants okay go
ahead um so you're saying if these
chemicals because they cannot be broken
down will forever be in that area would
the state of New Hampshire uh put some
kind of financial burden on this company
because of that for remediation purposes
I know Mike whims that yeah cuz that's
for the waste division director I'm a
toxicologist y I'll just I'll just add
very quickly I think that one one of the
issues here is that there's some thought
that there would be attenuation of these
chemicals if we eliminate the source
which was coming out of the Smoke Stack
that over time they although they don't
break down there would be some
attenuation um so uh the the amount
that's in the ground and in the
groundwater will eventually decline
somewhat but it's not due to breakdown
chemical representative Noel thank you
Mr chairman in Berlin in the Androgen
River we have dioxin which is a
comparable chemical it doesn't break
down and the the river now has a
classique uh uh grade in that section
where the dioxin is found and it's my
understanding your department comes up I
believe annually and tests uh in tests
the river catches fish and sees if any
dioxin is being accumulated that's how
it's being handled in the Andersen River
yeah so again that's something that I
would defer to the waste management
division for a more in-depth explanation
of how those kind of decisions are made
on attenuation plans but that is
something we do see with dioxins pcbs
Organic pesticides that have been used
for decades where if there's no
technology to remove them effectively
from the soil to break them down there
then the question is what's the
alternative
option
okay okay I will go ahead and proceed
back into more P discussion so um again
for everyone that hasn't met me before
I'm Dr jonath Pali I'm the toxicologist
with the New Hampshire Department
environmental services I've been here
since about 2018 working primarily on
past but also some of my time is spent
working on other contaminants that have
in the state so my role is to understand
how exposure to chemicals can lead to
health effects and help make
recommendations towards our standards
that are meant to be either Health
protective or to also look at specific
site investigations so at things like
super fund sites spills other things
that we have around the state and try to
inform that so when it comes to past I
think everyone's somewhat familiar with
this so I kept my part of the
presentation pretty high level because I
realize it's late in the day and I just
came after everyone else so I don't want
to punish everyone with chemical
structures but P stands for per and poly
floraly substances this is a very large
growing family of chemicals they are
characterized by having Florine attached
which gives them really unique
properties one of those main properties
is persistence and the ability to resist
degradation so when these end up in our
environment they don't necessarily break
down on a meaningful timeline these
chemicals like everything else they do
have halflife but that's on an order of
decades to centuries
so us and our grandchildren will be long
gone before several of these have
actually broken down in the
environment what is concerning for
several of these is that there is
potential for exposure and that is
primarily through ingestion or drinking
water that's the main way that these
chemicals get into most people's bodies
when we look around the state so if
you're looking at this map here these
are just private well results from
across New Hampshire and where it is
green means it is below our standard
where it is orange or yellow it is above
our state standard and where it is red
that means it is even higher than the
epa's previous unenforceable advisory
for these
compounds if you actually pull up one of
our maps that we do have on our website
you can also see that these compounds
are detected all of our soils and part
of that is because of releases from
industrial sites releases from old
landfill sites or where people had waste
and there's also potential that these
may be long range transported compounds
in the atmosphere
so for my role at the state it's trying
to understand how do these impact
People's Health and this is a rapidly
area or rapidly evolving area of
research so one of the things I also do
in my role is I participate in a lot of
Interstate work groups that works
amongst different states we also work
with our federal Partners we also work
with folks in the private research
sector and at the local universities to
try to understand what are the issues
with past how do we think about cleanup
of these reducing exposure and even here
in New Hampshire our program the
environmental health program has been
really successful in leveraging small
amounts of State funds to secure large
Federal funding to investigate specific
local P concerns so one of those issues
is basically what I call Magic where we
took $10,000 from our own State funding
we matched it with Dartmouth and we got
a $1 million Grant to understand past
impacts on some of our Coastal
ecosystems so it's trying to leverage
those resources our state expertise but
we're also trying to Boler up the
ability of local research institutions
to answer some of these questions so
it's not always the department having to
use our state funding to address these
problems because sometimes we have
issues related to site investigations
that we need to look into but there can
also be broader research questions that
we're not a research institution and
we're not staffed or resourced to answer
some of those questions so I'm really
proud of a lot of the Partnerships that
we developed within the state and we're
really actually building a lot of that
capacity to do more work
here
now one of the questions I believe we
got an email was explaining the
associations and causation relationship
between past health effects and exposure
and this is something that has been
reviewed in a lot of different settings
by either federal agencies International
groups independent panels various
programs that the federal government
including the national toxicology
program where they've looked at this and
they found that there are a lot of
associations between P but right when we
think about associations being causation
that's not the case but what they have
also looked at is the issue of is their
biological plausibility right so when we
look inside of animal model studies when
we look in human cell lines that have
been isolated when we look in cohort
studies that are held by the National
Cancer Institute do we see some of these
relationships and effects holding up and
we do so a lot of these seem to be
focused on effects on the immune system
system basic changes in lipid metabolism
and liver toxicity and some changes in
the hormones of our endocrine system and
right now actually the carcinogenicity
is being re-evaluated by the US EPA
because based on the available evidence
that they have to date they're looking
at reclassifying these as known
carcinogens at least one of the
compounds there have been some other
groups that have looked at this but
these are all sort of groups are kinding
with the same concern basically that we
see a lot of these associations there's
a lot of evidence for biological
plausibility there so it's not just
coincidence but what I will say is
there's a lot of debate about the
magnitude of it and that is one of the
areas that there is still uncertainty
that's one of the reasons where we see
new health assessments coming out all
the time about this is that question of
what's the strength of that relationship
so sort of the analogy I give is if
everyone in here spontaneously started
seeing five cents go into your bank
account every day that you never saw
before that is still significant what
would be more significant is if your
bank account Changed by 5% every day
that would be more
significant that's one of the things
that's being debated and that's actually
sort of behind where EPA has come up
with their proposed standards that have
not been finalized of lowering the
standard for PF actually establishing a
standard because they didn't have an
enforceable number before but for pfoa
and pfos to four parts per trillion
currently New Hampshire has m CLS which
are enforcable drinking water standards
for four of these compounds we have
individual numbers for those for two of
them EPA proposed separate numbers and
then there's a family of four past that
they've called a hazard index and I
didn't include a slide that's a bunch of
algebra but if anyone wants to see how
that's done I'm happy to do
it one things to bear in mind is this is
a proposed standard we are still waiting
for them to finalize that in the coming
weeks maybe um it seems to depend on who
you talk at talk to at the EPA where it
goes from weeks to months to maybe the
end of the year we're not entirely sure
at this point but something that's
important to note is these are for
Public Water Systems these are
enforcable standards in New Hampshire we
do have a groundwater standard which is
one of the things that drives a lot of
that private well testing that we did
and recommending people to pursue
treatment that's one of the reasons we
have a rebate program in the state it's
because nearly 47% of our residents in
the state are on private Wells they're
not public water systems that have the
resources to look into putting treatment
this so again we regulate for these in
drinking water our department is looking
at proposing essentially soil standards
for an additional set of these compounds
in the coming year that's still
something that is being proposed and
evaluated it would be a rule that would
come from our waste division but we're
also looking at setting for a limited
number of surface water bodies similar
standards because they are surface water
bodies that are used as drinking water
supplies for certain
communities but past exposure is
multifaceted it's not just drinking
water it's also food packaging consumer
products we're exposed to these
compounds in a lot of ways and that's
sort of what makes these unique compared
to a lot of other contaminants that
we've tried to evaluate oh
sorry sure um knowing that there's over
14,000 different past chemicals what
would it take for New Hampshire to
recognize past chemicals as a class so
one of the things we'd run into is
actually understanding which pasts occur
and which ones we can measure for and
actually having a way to treat them like
a class that way so I know in current
legislation I believe on product
packaging they Define pasas as any
carbon compound with a Florine on it we
don't have an ability to measure all of
those so we can't know if they're
actually there or present and even when
it comes to the larger 14,000 that could
potentially be out there a lot of those
are cast numbers for compounds that
simply aren't used in Commerce they
haven't made their way into the United
States they're hypothetical compounds
that can be designed in a computer
software and then assigned a cast number
so we would really focus more on which
compounds can we detect can we actually
measure for them what can we treat for
those would be a lot of the other
considerations that would go behind
um with regard to the the number of
chemicals I know that um I think I had
read that in the evaluation of the uh
the the exhaust from s Cain there were
108 past chemicals that were not
identified that they were detected but
but not identified um why is the state
of New Hampshire not getting a list of
the chemicals that are being used and
distributed from that facility so that
would be a question either for Waste
Management
again again because that would come down
to one what are the actual reporting
requirements for what a company brings
in and also do they actually know which
pasts are coming in raw product so
that's one of the things that with a lot
of folks looking at past across the
country there's this big thing of
intentional addition where you can also
have various pests that show up in a lot
of products that are unintentionally
added
and even with something coming out of a
stack or going through a process if it's
a byproduct of that then that's
different than having someone report
something that's inside of a product
that they're
using and I suggest you get his card and
she asked me maybe do a lot of this
questioning
offline yep it's 10 minutes at three so
yep so again just one of the challenges
with pasts compared to a lot of other
contaminants even things like dioxins
that were mentioned earlier is these are
in a lot of different media it's not
just a water issue it's not just a soil
issue it's we're finding it in a lot of
different places and that's what's
making it sort of unwieldly and
challenging to deal with and that's also
why it's getting a lot of attention
because we haven't had a class of
contaminants that affects so much
different media like this before yeah uh
thank you um and I realized we're all
over the map but I'm trying to get a
handle on you know how serious these
various things are um relatively and the
other one which is the elephant that's
been in the room for well it's been here
forever is arsenic and you know in terms
of uh the danger to humans how do they
all compare is there some way of rating
them comparatively so we do have some
ways of comparing those it's basically
where we compare doses the issue is that
they often cause different effects so we
run into of we're comparing apples to
oranges we can still compare the mass of
an apple to an orange but it's still not
quite the same comparison for pretty
much any of these contaminants when it
comes to drinking water if something is
classified as a carcinogen our goal
becomes zero and the limit that's set
there is what we think is feasible and
what people are willing to pay to get
that out of public water and that's
where the number four came from for
epa's number it's not the
definitive number that is safe according
to them it's a number that we can
reliably detect at this
point Y so we do have more information
on our website um there's a bunch of
YouTube videos that also include
presenting on the different work that
we've been doing whether it's from the
waste division from my own program from
work we've been doing with our academic
Partners Outreach we've done to
different communities and trying to
understand what concerns are so with
that I just wanted to open up for
questions cuz I realize we're near the
end of this and people may have specific
things that they want to get into
yep so when I was looking at the map
with the green and the red dots one of
the red dots looked like it was right at
my house oh I'm in Lebanon uh it's the
only Red Dot around so uh if I have a
constituent or myself who wants to get
there well tested to whom do I direct
them you can either direct them right to
my email information or if you go to
this website here pfast des.nh.gov
we have a Survey Monkey tool that they
can go fill out their information and
they can get in line for us to send a
sampler out to their house when we do
that past test it's a test for I believe
27 pasts right now is what the analyte
list is covering but we also do the
other standard well test for a lot of
the other contaminants that a lot of
people haven't ever tested for we're
learning that way if they need to get
some sort of treatment system installed
they're not just sort of ambulance
chasing the one contaminant they're
getting the slew of everything that
could be a concern and they get the
right technology and there is a rebate
program right now that if they are above
the state standards they can get up to
$5,000 for whole house treatment or if
it's feasible where they're at up to
about I believe $10,000 to connect to
public
water okay no other questions I guess oh
Lucius parshall has a question all right
Mr chair I know know it's getting late
the only thing we had left I think was
to give an update on the status of the
cprg Mike is that right so Mike's going
to do that the only thing I'm going to
kick it off with and I don't know if
Mike's going to cover this but when we
applied for this grant funding from EPA
the timelines that EPA put on the state
agency were unbelievably aggressive and
I'm just going to give a shout out to
some of my staff while Mike's looking
this up uh James Tilly Jen galberth Kurt
jingling and Brandon Wayman did an
amazing job in meeting these timelines
we're not there yet we still have more
timelines coming up but Mike's going to
cover all that but I felt the need to
give a shout out to my staff for for
meeting that initial March 1 timeline
which was incredibly
aggressive so I'm not sure why this is
showing the way that it is right now but
you also have this in on paper except
that oh it oh good okay so um and uh I
apologize at 9:00 last Monday night when
uh we were out of our building for some
construction and I thought we were
supposed to be here for this
presentation NE last week uh apparently
I couldn't count very well and so uh the
uh I think I left off over on the corner
here in terms of this this presentation
but uh it will be available I'll send it
to Christie and there may be some extra
copies out there so um so again I'm just
going to quickly address the uh cprg as
Craig mentioned we received a uh federal
government grant um of $3 million to uh
produce a what's called a preliminary
climate action plan the intent of that
plan is to set New Hampshire in a
position to where we could apply for
approximately $4.6 billion in federal
funding a a portion of not just New
Hampshire um and and uh so the uh
requirement was to produce this uh
preliminary climate action plan over the
course of the Fall we did engagement
around the state we got a lot of input
from stakeholders we reached out to um
uh a wide variety one emphasis of this
program is also to provide benefits to
what are known as EJ areas um uh
lowincome and disadvantaged areas 40% of
the benefit um uh needs to go there so
we engaged the uh uh
lowincome uh community in New Hampshire
and um did did a lot of Outreach work
presenting this uh held several seminars
webinars uh over the fall and winter and
we um met that very aggressive timeline
of producing the pcap um by March 1st we
submitted that um on on March 1st to
EPA and uh that put us in a position
where we could then apply uh uh April
for first uh our application is due for
that portion of federal funding that
would go uh potentially go to New
Hampshire our intent is to apply for
what's known as a a certain tier of that
funding which is up to 50 million we're
going to apply for that we're also part
of Statewide Coalition that uh a number
of states uh one Coalition led by Hawaii
and 13 other states um is applying for
money to be used for resilience for
municipal
uh facilities such as wastewater
treatment plants and so on to be able to
install solar energy and to be able to
at times when the grid is down continue
to operate um and then there is a New
England Coalition of States that's
applying for $500 million the Hawaii one
is also 500 million and uh they're
applying for a uh a heat pump coalition
to uh provide incentives for heat pumps
uh to be uh deployed in New England
states so we're part of uh those two to
multi-state coalitions as well as our
own internal State Co um
application and um I'm not going to
spend a lot of time on all the uh
components of the plan and so on again
I'll provide you with a copy of this
can
there um again the timeline we we've
covered um we we've met everything so
far um we're working right now um I
don't know how many of you know but the
intricacies of developing a 50 million
application for federal funding um uh is
almost takes almost the 50 million
itself to Pro develop the application um
but we're we're in the throws of that
and uh working EXT extremely hard and I
would Echo Craigs um work on the staff
we the these people have been working
weekends nights and uh doing a
tremendous amount of work um the key
components that we're seeking uh funding
for would be Transportation sector
measures some EV charging um uh um uh
consumer incentives public transit uh
expanding public transit uh Residential
Building sector there was significant
interest and what's known as pre-
weatherization and weatherization
programs where um pre- weiz is basically
before you do weatherization on a
building um the building may not be uh
in a in a condition so you have to do
some work on the structure of the
building and so on before you can
actually apply installation and do all
that so um there's a tremendous need for
for that type of those type of programs
um local government resilience energy as
I mentioned and Energy Efficiency
improvements on drinking water um and
Water Systems those in addition to
reducing emissions they also save money
for municipalities on taxes the more
efficient the pumps and so on are the
less electricity they have to use the
less cost um and uh uh there's some also
some programs on food waste diversion
and also Workforce Development one of
the biggest issues that we have in this
arena is we need a tremendous amount of
of for instance weatherization pre-
weatherization work to be done there's
not enough contractors to do the work
and there's not enough not a trained
Workforce so that's a big issue and
we're hoping to address that through
some of this funding as well um the
timeline coming up is is uh in July we
anticipate being notified by EPA again
there was 4.6 billion I'm sure there'll
be about a hundred billion dollar in
requests from States so how that gets
allocated and the way they the decisions
they make there um we don't know but um
we anticipate Awards being
uh issued in October and uh this uh
funding also requires us to produce
what's known as a comprehensive climate
action plan which is a followup to the
pcap and uh uh further some of this work
but also to implement the uh whatever
funding we do receive and we anticipate
um of of good we we we have high hopes
for the two coalitions that were
involved in to receive those fundings
and again those are 500 $ 10000 million
program so you know we would hope to
receive maybe 5 or 10% of that um so the
potential for funding through the
coalitions is probably greater than our
our internal State application potential
but again that's all up to EPA we don't
we don't have any um any say over that
and um again this is the broad
objectives of the cprg program and
that's where we are right now so I'd be
happy to uh to take questions and end
pain uh as uh as we've represent with a
lot representative Kaplan has a question
yeah I just first of all I want to
Salute Your department and and you know
congratulate you on meeting that
timeline it was as you say it must have
been a tremendous effort it's it's taken
a pound of flesh out of a lot of people
I bet um I just had a question about the
public transport I mean you mentioned
one of the goals is to expand public
transport in state and since we have you
know practically zero public transport
in the state what would where would you
know like what how how ambitious is that
plan um it's ambitious but it's also a
relatively smaller part of the funding
um amount that we we would apply for um
we've talked with bus companies here in
the state and uh uh Regional Transit um
providers Manchester Transit Etc so um
if we were to again we're applying for
$50 million if EPA gives us 20
you know we're going to have to reall
decide how how we're going to allocate
that and so on we don't we don't know
that um and so uh again once the once
the awards are announced um but it would
go to people like MTA nationa Transit
Etc to expand their uh Transit
opportunities and particularly in
areas just to follow up you're not
talking about a Statewide network of of
any sort at this point no no we're
talking about enhancing existing
programs yeah yeah yeah and I mean there
may be some for smaller Transit
operators that that you know do local in
in in other areas and so on WE we've
been talking with with a wide variety
but again it's all dependent on how much
we
receive okay seeing no other questions
we really appreciate you guys being here
that was a great update and a great
presentation and and uh got lots to work
on and lots to talk about so thank you
very much appreciate the opportunity so
that's it for science technology and
energy for today Tuesday the 19th of
March we will probably be back here
March 26 which is next Tuesday but I
don't know that for certain yet so keep
your eye on your
email and uh with that we'll see you all
on Thursday take
care
hey Ned how are you he good
yeah we I'll send it to the committee
and
Y I almost did and then I didn't want to
ask you publicly about this option but I
would love to see y in the
transportation sector
Hampshire
this right we have some tremendous rail
trail quds y namely the Sea Coast all
the way to Manchester right lovely rail
trail guess what it's m it's not paved
unusable
e
for